Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute ist alles anders, denn heute sind wir live in Darmstadt und ich begrüße alle herzlich, die gekommen sind. Hallo. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja über 50 Sendungen durch. Das ist schon eine ganze Menge Holz. Nahezu alle zwei Wochen schlägt diese Sendung auf und wir dachten uns, jetzt machen wir mal was ganz anderes. So richtig neu war die Idee nicht, aber es dauert ja dann immer eine Weile, bis sowas dann auch tatsächlich mal zur Realisierung kommt, auch wenn ich immer sehr drauf gedrängt habe. Aber das ist etwas, was ich auch schon gelernt habe, hier in meinen Zeiten als Gast bei der Raumfahrt, dass die Dinge dann doch immer sehr lange brauchen und die müssen immer sehr sorgfältig geplant werden. Und da müssen dann sehr viele Gremien auch zustimmen und dann haben wir noch irgendwelche Einwände und dann muss das nochmal umgeplant werden und dann klappt auch mal ein Start nicht, der man eigentlich schon ins Auge gefasst hatte. Also fast wie im richtigen Leben. Aber am Ende ist es dann doch immer ganz toll. Und deswegen sitzen wir jetzt hier und auch tatsächlich mit der ursprünglich geplanten Crew-Besatzung. Und ich begrüße hier als Mitastronauten auf meiner kleinen Reise Volker Schmid vom DLR und Rainer Kresken.
Schön, dass wir immer wieder hier sitzen und ein bisschen so unter uns über Raumfahrt plaudern können, finde ich klasse.
Ja, wir haben ja schon mal geplaudert und du bist ja in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen schuld. Du weißt warum?
Ich ahne ja.
Ja, ich bin ja mal mit meinem kleinen Privat-Podcast-Koffer mal vorbeigekommen und dachte mir, klopf mal so bei der Raumfahrt an und guck mal, was sich alles so erzählen lässt. Ich hab jetzt auch noch auf der Fahrt hierher mir die Sendung noch mal angehört, was du mir damals alles schon so mitgeteilt hattest. Und da war ich ja noch ein totaler Raumfahrt Newbie. Mittlerweile kann ich ja schon richtig angeben, weil man lernt ja eine ganze Menge. Und Raumzeit ist auf jeden Fall auch immer so ein Format gewesen, wo das Lernen auch sehr im Vordergrund steht. Das ist ja grundsätzlich eigentlich bei so einem Format so. Aber hier war das für mich wirklich auch eine sehr interessante Reise, wie man dann eigentlich so mit seinem typischen Basiswissen, mit dem man so gemeinhin ausgestattet ist, sich so langsam peu a peu in den Orbit hinaufschaukelt. Unser Podcast hat das ja dann so ein bisschen ausgelöst. Ich fange dann auch gleich mal mit dir an. Vorstellen müssen wir dich ja trotzdem. Weil bei Raumzeit selber warst du ja noch nicht dabei. Du bist bei der ESA genauer, beim ESOC. Und du sorgst dafür, dass die Dinger nicht runterfallen.
Kann man so sagen. Ich arbeite in einem problematischen Arbeitsplatz. Zunächst mal gibt es da vier astronomische Forschungs-Satelliten. XMM, Integral, Herschel und Planck. Das sind teure Hightech-Geräte, die von Ingenieuren betreut werden müssen. Dann gibt es da Wissenschaftler, die wollen diese Forschungsinstrumente gerne benutzen, um die Daten zu produzieren, die sie gerne haben wollen. Und ich bin so eigentlich das Bindeglied zwischen diesen beiden Parteien. Ich sorge dafür, dass der Satellit das macht und das beobachtet, was die Wissenschaftler gerne sehen wollen. Also in meinem Team sind wir vollkommen einer Meinung. Wir könnten die Satelliten auch problemlos ohne Wissenschaftler betreiben. Aber trotzdem, wir hätten da genug zu tun. Echt, da kennt keine Langeweile auf. Aber wir möchten gerne, dass diese Dinger den Nutzen bringen, den man geplant hat. Nämlich, die sollen Kultur produzieren, die sollen Wissenschaft produzieren und das machen wir. Das ist unser Job bei ESOG.
Außerdem bist du ja auch ansonsten immer ein munterer Gesprächspartner und wirst so durch die Veranstaltungen durchgereicht, weil du dich ja auch so, ich sag mal, so ein bisschen mehr mit der Historie der Raumfahrt speziell auseinandergesetzt hast. Da reden wir bestimmt auch gleich noch mal ein bisschen drüber. Und das war ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Teil der Motivation, heute hier auch das Thema so ein bisschen zu umschreiben. Festnageln würde ich jetzt mal nicht sagen, weil wie das immer so ist am Anfang eines solchen Gesprächs, weiß man gar nicht so richtig, wo man dann am Ende landet. Aber natürlich sind diese ganzen Mythen, die sich so um die Raumfahrt ranken, auch immer ein wichtiges Begleitthema, dem Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt werden muss. Komme ich mal zu Volker. Hallo. Willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist beim DLR, und zwar genauer beim DLR Raumfahrtmanagement in Bonn. Das sind schon mal interessante Informationen, dass es sowas auch gibt. Wir hatten ja hier schon einige Gesprächspartner vom Raumfahrtmanagement. Das waren übrigens mit die überraschendsten Gespräche bei Raumzeit für mich und in gewisser Hinsicht auch für die Hörer überraschend, weil sie nicht nur überraschend interessant waren, sondern auch immer überraschend lang. Überhaupt habe ich die Erkenntnis gewonnen, dass umso unwirklicher der Titel von irgendetwas ist, umso spannender ist dann das Thema am Ende. Was ist denn deine Aufgabe beim Raumfahrtmanagement?
Also wir haben spannende Themen. Meine Aufgabe im Raumfahrtmanagement ist in der Abteilung für bemannte Raumfahrt, ISS und Exploration. Dort die Betreuung des ATVs, des praktisch europäischen unbemannten Raumtransporters. Den betreue ich seit 2001 dort. Und darüber hinaus leite ich dort die Fachgruppe ISS. Wir bereiten jetzt aktuell mit den ESA-Kollegen gerade die Mission von Alexander Gerst für kommendes Jahr vor. Nicht nur praktisch von der ESA-Seite her, gibt es ja einen Haufen Experimente aus dem ELIPS-Programm, das Forschungsprogramm oder Nutzungsprogramm für die Raumstation, sondern eben auch, wir sehen zu, dass Gerst dann vom nationalen Bereich her, also vom DLR selber, Experimente und Tätigkeiten praktisch beigestellt kriegt, um so ein bisschen den nationalen Charakter der Mission auch zu betonen. Es ist natürlich eine ESA-Mission, aber es ist der erste deutsche seit langer Zeit, seit Thomas Reiter in 2006, und das wollen wir natürlich ein bisschen hervorheben. Ja, und wir beschäftigen uns natürlich auch mit Projekten, die rund um Raumfahrt, also vis-à-vis Industrie, vergeben Aufträge, vergeben Zuwendungen an Institute und Universitäten. Und das rundet unser Feld so ein bisschen ab. Und ich selber bin noch im EUB, im Exploration and Utilization Board, der ESA, der Deutsche Delegierte. Und da geht es eben auch um Nutzungsthemen für die Raumstation. Ich sage mal, hier jetzt die großen Themen EML, die Electromagnetic Levitator, ACES ist so ein Schlagwort, die Atomic Clock, wer das vielleicht schon mal gehört hat. Das sind Themen, die werden im EUB behandelt und werden dort diskutiert, also fachlich. Und dann dort auch entschieden und weitergereicht an das nächste Gremium. Da hat es das eingangs ja schon angesprochen, dass viele Gremien zustimmen müssen und so weiter. Und wir vom Raumfahrtmanagement haben eben viele spannende Themen und bewegen uns eben stark auf der Papierseite. Aber die Hardware kommen nie zu kurz. Ich bin immer bei ATV, immer oft in Bremen und bin sehr auch interessiert, dass da halt alles entsprechend gut...
Also nur weil das jetzt Management heißt, hat der nicht alle so Managertypen?
Nein. Also wir die meisten haben ein naturwissenschaftliches Studium hinter sich, haben als Ingenieur gearbeitet oder Physiker, Chemiker. Es gibt eine ganz interessante Ansammlung von Kollegen. Manche sind Biologen, Mikrobiologen, Astronomen, Astrophysiker, ist also alles vertreten.
Was ist denn dein eigener Hintergrund?
Ich bin Raumfahrt-Ingenieur, hab in Aachen studiert, hab vor dem Studium eine Lehre in Handwerk gemacht, bin gelernter Metaller, Feinmechaniker. Ja, das ist so mein Hintergrund. Also ich hab die Dinge, die fliegen, auch schon auf Drehmaschine gehabt, auf der Drehbank, wie es viele auch schon gemacht haben. Ja, wenn die Kapseln noch von Hand, dann geht es direkt vom Manager. Es hilft schon, wenn es darum geht, technische Dinge zu beurteilen. Ich hab es also immer als Privileg empfunden, praktisch aus dem Handwerk und Industrie mal reingeguckt zu haben, damit man Dinge, wenn Probleme besprochen werden, wenn ein Ventil nicht funktioniert oder irgendein technisches Problem auftaucht, dass man mitreden kann. Man muss sich natürlich schlau machen und unter Umständen auch auf Schraubenebene runtergehen vom System, aber es ist hilfreich.
Ich will der Industrie und den anderen Firmen jetzt nicht unrecht tun, aber ich hab immer so häufig den Eindruck, dass man doch häufig so einen Disconnect findet, dass die da oben, die so entscheiden, mit den tatsächlichen technischen Prozessen, die letzten Endes so das Geschäft ausmachen, dann gar nicht mehr so viel zu tun haben und da noch eine ganze Menge schief läuft. Das ist irgendwie etwas, was sich die Raumfahrt eigentlich gar nicht leisten kann und meiner Meinung nach auch nicht tut.
Ja, also ich sehe das ein bisschen differenziert. Es gibt natürlich Extreme auf beiden Seiten. Aber ich denke, es braucht natürlich Leute unten an der Basis, die das System herstellen. Und man braucht natürlich auch die Produkt-Sicherungsleute, die Qualitätsleute, die Entwickler vor allen Dingen. Und dann natürlich auch die Leute, die das in der ESA oder in Europa vorantreiben, in Gremien. Die Gremienarbeit ist nun mal da. Es sind viele Mitgliedsstaaten und viele Programmteilnehmer unter Umständen bei so was. Und das muss natürlich alles bedacht werden. Und ja klar, es macht es nicht immer einfach. Es ist manchmal auch zäh. Aber am Ende klappt es eigentlich doch erstaunlich gut. Und wenn man guckt, was, ich sage jetzt mal ESA und mit ihren Mitgliedstaaten, nehmen wir jetzt mal ATV oder auch ISS, was man da auf die Beine stellt mit vielen Beteiligten. Bei ATV sind es 30 Industriebetriebe aus 10 Ländern. Und das Ding funktioniert. Also das ist schon, muss ich sagen, also Lob an die Industrie und Lob an die ESA, die das managen und machen. Und klar, es mag schneller gehen, wenn man, bei NASA zum Beispiel, die haben natürlich nicht so viele Partner, wo sie sich abstimmen müssen. Aber vielleicht sind sie nicht mehr effizient wie wir in Europa. Mehr will ich dazu eigentlich gar nicht sagen. Ich denke, das kann sich jeder selber bewerten anhand den Erfolgen, die man sieht. Geht auch mal natürlich was schief, aber...
Meistens klappt es.
So, aber so ein bisschen mit den Mythen hast du es ja auch. Du bist so eigener Autor im Science-Fiction-Bereich. Was sind deine erste Science-Fiction-Prägungen gewesen?
Meine erste Science-Fiction-Prägung, das war seinerzeit Time Tunnel und Raumschiff Enterprise natürlich. Also Raumschiff Enterprise eigentlich hauptsächlich. Das erste sozusagen, das UR? Ja, die Original-Serie und dann später natürlich Raumpatrouille, die Kult-Serie, nach der wir gefiebert haben als Kids. Unglaublich. Und es gab ja damals kein Internet. Wir haben natürlich die Romane verschlungen. Seit den 80er Jahren im Deutschunterricht schreibe ich selber eine kleine Serie mit vielen Unterbrechungen und im Stile Raumpatrouille, Wing Commander, Battlestar Galactica. In dem Genre ist das angesiedelt und macht Spaß. Ich mache viele Lesungen, auch in Planetarien mit Musik dabei. Es macht Spaß. Ich finde das Thema heute hervorragend. Raumfahrt und Science Fiction und die Mythen, ich finde, das ist höchste Zeit für die Zukunft.
Gut gesagt. Genau, höchste Zeit für die Zukunft. Das wird sich auch jemand wie Jules Verne gedacht haben, als er mal gedacht hat, immer nur dieses öde Rumgestapfe auf der Erde mit all der Schwerkraft, das bringt es ja eh nicht. Man müsste ja mal zum Mond. Ich bin ja auch nicht so ein Science Fiction Experte, muss ich sagen. Aber mein Eindruck ist immer gewesen, an Jules Verne macht sich eigentlich eine ganze Menge fest. Er hat schon diese Schwelle überschritten. Ich meine, es werden auch schon andere in die Zukunft geblickt haben. Also diese konkrete Kopplung der Zukunft und der Technik, das hat sich dort extrem raumgegriffen. Und das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was die Science Fiction so ein bisschen ausmacht, dass die Wissenschaft auf einmal anfängt zu träumen, wie die Dinge denn jetzt eigentlich sein könnte oder zumindest irgendjemand anfängt, mal zu erträumen, was die Wissenschaft im Prinzip irgendwann mal tun sollte. Und dann war ja dieses Versprechen im Raum so, naja, so ein Mond wäre jetzt mal ganz gut, könnte man jetzt eigentlich mal hinfliegen. Und die Wissenschaftler haben sich halt noch so mit Raumkrümmungen beschäftigt, bevor man irgendwie überhaupt nur mal vom Boden abheben konnte. Was ist denn so euer Eindruck, wann im Prinzip die Wissenschaft auch wirklich diese Science Fiction das erste Mal aufgenommen hat?
Also das war sicherlich auch schon Jules Verne. Also der hatte wirklich eine sehr, sehr gute naturwissenschaftliche Bildung und hat sich überlegt, was aus diesen technischen Lego-Steinen, die es damals schon gab, irgendwie auch zu einem Mondflug passen würde. Also vieles von dem, was Jules Verne sich da ausgedacht hat, das kann man auch im wahren Leben wiederfinden. Natürlich der Start in einer Kanonenkugel zum Mond lieber nicht, das ist irgendwie nicht gut für alle Beteiligten, aber er hat sich wirklich konkrete Gedanken gemacht, wie das in so einem Raumschiff auch vor sich geht und da muss man schon Respekt vorhaben.
Was war denn da so realistisch?
Er hat sich zum Beispiel überlegt, wie der Raumflug tatsächlich so vonstatten geht. Was passiert, wenn sich die Raumkapsel dem Schwerpunkt des Erde-Monds-Systems nähert? Das hat er nicht richtig hingekriegt, aber er hat sich da Gedanken drüber gemacht und hat das auch in seinen Roman einfließen lassen. Und er hat das so gemacht, dass man es wirklich gerne liest und dass es wirklich unterhaltsam ist. Also Hut ab, ich lese die Romane von Jules Verne wirklich sehr gerne und das macht wirklich Spaß. Und man kann da auch das wirklich über Mühen sehen, also die technische Realität wiederzugeben, was ihm realistisch erschien.
Vieles kommt einem ja immer nicht realistisch vor. Ich weiß noch, wie ich mal in meiner Jugend völlig entsetzt einen James-Bond-Film geschaut habe, wo er das erste Mal so ein Navigationsgerät im Auto hat und so ein kleiner blinkender Punkt sagt ihm, wo er ist, irgendwo so mitten in der Pampa. Ich war ganz entrüstet und dachte mir so, das geht gar nicht. Ja, so pifikus. Das hatte ich schon verstanden, dass dafür die Infrastruktur überhaupt nicht da ist. Im Prinzip müsste es den Wissenschaftlern mit dem ganzen Science-Fiction auch so gegangen sein. Hier Rakete und so weiter, geht ja gar nicht, das haben wir ja gar nicht. Der nächste Schritt wäre dann, warum eigentlich nicht?
Genau.
Also ich meine, ist Juvern daran schuld, dass wir zum Mond geflogen sind?
Sicherlich auch, aber ich glaube, wenn ich da jetzt mal wirklich einen Namen nennen sollte, der schuld daran ist, dass wir zum Mond fliegen, dann ist das Konstantin Tsiolkovsky, der Russe. Dieser Mann ist ein Phänomen, der hat sich 1911 oder so ein, 1911, ich glaube schon, um die Zeit herum jedenfalls, der hat sich wirklich überlegt, wie können Menschen ins All gelangen? Und der ist derjenige, der zum ersten Mal die beiden Begriffe Raumfahrt und Rakete zusammengebracht hat. Der war Grundschullehrer, hatte elf Geschwister, die Eltern waren bettelarm, und der hat solche Ideen da im russischen Dorf gehabt. Der hat sich dann in den Zug gesetzt, ist nach Moskau gefahren, hat sich Mathe-Wücher beschafft, um das konkret auszurechnen, was er ihm da im Kopf rumschmörte. Und dann hat er auch wirklich konkrete Vorschläge gemacht, wie man das umsetzen kann. Er hat erkannt, dass man mit einer Rakete nur dann ins Orbit kommen kann, wenn man das Stufenprinzip anwendet. Das hat er sich damals aus dem Finger gesogen. Er hat ihm aufgefallen, dass man flüssige Treibstoffe braucht, um die nötige Energiedichte dahin zu kriegen. Also so viel von dem, was der Mensch sich ausgedacht hat, ist tatsächlich nachher ins All geflogen, das ist unverstellbar.
Das heißt, er war eigentlich gar kein Wissenschaftler in dem Sinne?
Nein, er war kein Wissenschaftler. Er war jemand wie du und ich. Er hatte keinerlei wissenschaftliche Ausbildung. Er hatte nur Ideen und wollte die tatsächlich umsetzen. Er hat alles getan, was in seiner Macht stand, das zu tun. Er hat diese ganzen Sachen in Russland auch ans Laufen gebracht. Solche Leute wie Korolev, der tatsächlich den ersten Raumflug umgesetzt hat, der hat direkt von Tsiolkovsky gelernt, hat auch als junger Mann seine Bücher von Tsiolkovsky gelesen und hat draußen am Feld Raketen gebaut, die ihm ständig um die Ohren geflogen sind. Aber er hat es geschafft, diese Dinge wirklich in ein funktionstüchtiges technisches System zu bringen. So funktioniert das eigentlich. Einer muss sagen, das geht und zwar so, dann kommt die nächste Generation, die macht das, dann funktioniert es. Das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Dieses Gespann aus Tchaikovsky und Koroliov-Ruth ab, was die geschafft haben.
Gibt es überhaupt noch einen Nachfolger von Jules Verne, der da jetzt auch literarisch nachgereicht hat, bevor diese allgemeine Begeisterung für die Raumfahrt ausgebrochen ist?
Ich denke mal Asimov und Kubrick vielleicht. Was mich an Jules Verne noch fasziniert, ist, dass Jules Verne seinen Geschoss aus Florida gestartet hat. Eigentlich schon mit der bekannten Inklination und auch wieder im Wasser gelandet ist. Also schon erste Präjudizien geschaffen hat für Apollo.
Da gibt es Bilder in dem Buch, die sehen genauso aus wie die Fotos von der Mondlandung. Man sieht im Hintergrund ein Schiff, ersetzte USS Hornet durch einen Raddampfer, glaube ich. Dann sieht man die Kapsel, die da im Meer dümpelt. Und dann kommen da Hilfsboote, die den Ex-Astronauten da raushelfen. Das ist ein 1 zu 1 Vorgriff auf das, was tatsächlich passiert ist. Und gerade bei solchen Details muss ich sagen...
Da muss man sich ja wieder fragen, haben die Amerikaner jetzt sozusagen ihre Raumbasis nur deshalb in Florida gebaut, weil das da sozusagen dort schon beschrieben wurde?
Das glaube ich nicht, aber...
Naja, es gab da einen greifbaren technischen Modus.
Also es hätte ja auch noch andere Optionen gegeben, oder?
Nee, für die USA gab es eigentlich nur diese eine Option, kann man so sagen. Also für einen Bementenflug mit der Möglichkeit...
Weil südlich und Wasser daneben?
Ja, weil es war so weit wie möglich südlich und von Meer umgeben, genau. Spreier-Schuss-Bahn nach Osten, das zählte da.
Okay, man hätte ja mal später auch Vandenberg untersucht, eben praktisch auf der anderen Seite an der Westküste und das hat man dann aber für bemannte Staats, glaube ich, verworfen irgendwann. Ja, ich denke einfach, genau wie in Russland hat man Startplätze einfach gewählt, wo wenig los war, wo jetzt in speziellen USA Wasser da ist, um eben die Sicherheit auch entsprechend zu berücksichtigen, das Risiko zu minimieren und das fand ich bei Jules Verne extrem faszinierend, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, er hat sogar in seinem Roman auch die richtige Geschwindigkeit angegeben, die man braucht, um von der Erde zum Mond zu gelangen. Also, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Aber das fand ich schon bemerkenswert.
Aber die Russen ziehen da jetzt erst nach, ne? So Baikonur und so, dem war das eigentlich egal, dass das alles auf den Boden fällt.
Ja gut, da ist natürlich wenig Besiedelung da in der kasachischen Steppe. Und jetzt geht man ja weiter, gehen Osten nach Worstodtschnee. Und bei Placettes gibt es ja auch noch ein Startzentrum. Also je nach Mission eben. Die hatten ja nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, Wasser zu erreichen. Also sie mussten über Land gehen.
Hat auch früher keiner nachgefragt. Und heute ist das ein beliebter Rohstoff-Sammler. Also jedes Mal, wenn jetzt eine Use-Rakete gestartet wird, dann versammeln die sich da in den Zielpunkt und versuchen, da die Booster-Raketen einzusammeln.
Die seltenen Erden fallen sozusagen direkt vom Himmel.
Ja, die Leute finden das Risiko da vertretbar im Ausgleich für das, was man dabei abholen kann.
Ein Großteil wird nach China verkauft, der Rohstoffe.
Es war ja die Mondlandung, die war ja irgendwie im Kopf. Und irgendwann hat es ja dann auch zumindest die USA erreicht. Ich überspringe jetzt so ein bisschen diese ganze Entstehungsgeschichte, die ja lange Zeit vor allem auch von militärischen Gelüsten und Krieg stark geprägt war mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Als das dann vorüber war, trat aber im Prinzip eigentlich erst so diese Phase ein, wo das, was wir heute so als Raumfahrt kennen, eigentlich wirklich erst Fleisch geworden ist. Die Russen hatten dann die Nase vorn, das ist ja allgemein bekannt, mit dem Sputnik und das hat so die Amerikaner in diese Moment mal, das wäre doch jetzt eigentlich unsere Aufgabe gewesen, Situation gebracht. Und dann ging es ja sozusagen schon mehr oder weniger nur noch um den Mond.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also die Amerikaner haben gesehen, dass sie die Russen nicht mehr schlagen konnten in der Erdneran-Umlaufbahn. Die haben da alle firsts gehabt, den ersten Satelliten, die erste mannte Raumkapsel mit Juri Gagarin, ersten Mehrfachflüge, erste Frau, alles solche Sachen. Da konnte man die Russen nicht mehr schlagen. Aber die Amerikaner haben gesehen, dass man da in diesem Wettrennen schon noch was machen kann, wenn man aus diesem Sprint in die Erdumlaufbahn praktisch einen Marathon zum Mond macht. Da kann man noch was holen. Und es war auch ein unglaublicher Zufall, dass zu der Zeit die richtigen Leute zusammenkamen. Erst mal befanden sich die USA auch noch in einer ungeahnten wirtschaftlichen Blüte, die erstmal die Kohle bereitgestellt hat für diese ganzen Sachen. Und dann gab es noch einen Präsidenten, der positive Visionen hatte, der John F. Kennedy, der war wirklich inspiriert, möchte man sagen. Der hat wirklich mitgekriegt, was da gerade die Zeit so brachte. Und er hat das umgesetzt und das auch für die USA nutzvoll umgesetzt. Und dann gab es natürlich auch Ingenieur-Genies wie Werner von Braun, die auch dabei waren und die technischen Geräte schaffen konnten. Und so kam das alles zusammen. Und es kam natürlich auch ein ungebremster Zukunftsglauben in der amerikanischen Bevölkerung dazu. Also das Projekt Apollo, das wirklich einen Haufen Geld gekostet hat, war niemals irgendwie politisch umstritten. Da musste man keine Wahlkampfreden halten. Da rannte man weit offene Türen ein als Politiker, wenn man da Raumfahrt betreiben wollte. Und das waren traumhafte Zustände.
Und die Amerikaner hatten, wie Volker ja schon gesagt hat, auch Stanley Kubrick, der das dann alles produziert hat.
Sagen manche Leute, ja, ich beschäftige mich. Ich beschäftige mich gern mit der Szene. Also Tim hat einen schönen Begriff geprägt, nämlich der Begriff Mondlandungsopfer. Damit sind so Leute gemeint, denen wie ich die Gnade der frühen Geburt zuteil geworden sind. Also Leute, die die Möglichkeit hatten, 1969 bewusst vom Fernseher zu sitzen und so den Zeitgeist da als kleiner Junge oder als kleines Mädchen einzuatmen. Ich war dabei, ich hab vom Fernseher gesessen.
Wie klein warst du da?
Jedenfalls, ich hab das wirklich bewusst erlebt und von da an war das alles klar, wie mein Leben abläuft, im Großen und Ganzen. Jedenfalls hab ich mich da als kleiner Junge wirklich reingesteigert. Ich hab das wirklich sehr aufmerksam verfolgt. Und das hat auch dazu geführt, dass ich mich für Naturwissenschaft und Technik interessiert hab. Ich hab Abitur gemacht und bin dann an die RWTH nach Aachen gerannt, hab dann Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik studiert. Ist das Zufall?
Bestimmt nicht.
Jedenfalls war das auch schon klar. Ich hab damit bei Professoren gelernt, die auch beim Apollo-Projekt mitgearbeitet haben. Das war eine tolle Sache. Professor Thome war in der Flugdynamik auch damals. Er hat da jede Menge aus den L-Kästen erzählt. Ja, wir haben das damals so gemacht auf dem Flug zum Mond. Damals wurde ich dann noch mal nachgeimpft, mit diesem ganzen Apollo-Fieber. Und danach ist das ein bisschen eingeschlafen bei mir. Ich hab diese Sache innerlich abgehakt. Und dann irgendwann, zack, Ende der 90er-Jahre, gab es das Internet. Und schon ist das Internet zwei Tage da, kommen da die ersten Apollo-Verschwörungstheorien auf. Und ich hab dieser Sache zunächst mal nicht die richtige Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt. Aber irgendwann wiegelte sich das ein bisschen auf. Und da war ich dabei. Und das mit den Verschwörungsgeschichten ist eine problematische Sache. Das ist ein Thema, das von sich aus an sich zwischen menschlichen Sprengstoff birgt. Diese Verschwörungstheoretiker sind Leute, die sich unheimlich smart finden. Und die sind auch selbstbewusst und schaffensfreudig. Die schauen sich da irgendwelche Sachen an, irgendwelche technischen Dokumentationen und finden da anscheinend irgendwelche Widersprüche. Und die Leute treten dann selbstbewusst vor die Welt und sagen, die NASA hat die Mondlandung gefällt. Und dann kommt der Kresken und ruft Bullshit. Also das ist eine Situation, da ist Stunk vorprogrammiert. Und ich muss auch sagen, in der Hinsicht bin ich auch ein bisschen auf Randale gebürstet. Also ich bin gerne bereit, mich mit den Leuten auseinanderzusetzen. Und das führt immer wieder zu interessanten Situationen. Ich habe einen Vortrag seit fast acht Jahren –waren die Amerikaner auf dem Mond –der wird gerne gehört. Und ich habe da auch immer ganz gute Zuhörerschaft. Und in diesem Vortrag lasse ich diese Verschwörungstheoretiker zu Wort kommen und erzähle den geneigten Hörern, warum diese Verschwörungstheoretiker daneben liegen. Das ist eine tolle Sache, weil die Verschwörungstheoretiker –das muss man einfach sagen –kreativ sind. Die erschaffen irgendwelche Fakten aus dem Nichts. Und da muss man das erstmal widerlegen. Und aus diesem Anlass habe ich mich überhaupt wieder der Apollo-Geschichte zugewandt. Ich musste da wirklich eine Menge recherchieren. Und ich musste mir auch mehrere Meter DVDs aus den USA beschaffen, um das Original-Filmmaterial zu bekommen, um den Leuten die Originale dann wirklich vor die Nase zu setzen und zu sagen, nein, was da wirklich zu sehen ist, ist das und das. Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile auch seit ein paar Jahren wirklich richtig tolle Bücher über die Apollo-Mission, von denen ich damals geträumt hätte. Wir waren damals noch auf Informationen von Werner Büdler und Günter Sieffert aus der ARD angewiesen. Heute weiß ich, wo die ihr Wissen her hatten. Es gab damals von der NASA einen sehr schönen Press-Kit, also eine Press-Information-Matte, die da eine ganze Weisheit her hatten. Heute gibt es das natürlich auch im Internet, zum Unterladen, aber es gibt tolle Literatur, die weit darüber hinausgeht und die sich auch ausdrücklich an Leute wendet, die als technisch interessiert allein eigentlich wissen möchten, wie das gemacht ist. Das kann ich auch schön in einen Vortrag einflechten. Wenn ich dann mit meinem Vortrag am Ende bin, ist das Verschwörungsthema eigentlich durch. Ich hab dann typischerweise noch ein oder zwei Leute im Publikum, die den Scheiß noch glauben. Aber die meisten Leute finden das klasse, dass man mal erzählt, warum das, was die Verschwörungstheoretiker da vorbringen, falsch ist und wie man das entkräftet. Die Leute wollen auch nicht mehr wissen, ist das jetzt gefälscht? Nichts, sondern die wollen wissen, wie haben die Amerikaner das gemacht? Wie hat das geklappt mit der Bahnbestimmung? Wie haben die die Raketen gezündet? Und all solche Sachen und das gefällt mir. Ich bin überhaupt, was so Vorträge angeht, eine Rampensau. Ich mache jetzt gerne mit Leuten, was da in der Raumfahrt vor sich geht und wie das funktioniert.
Wir werden uns ja schon darüber unterhalten. Dein erstes Gegenargument, das fand ich eigentlich schon sehr überzeugend, warum die Amerikaner auf jeden Fall auf dem Mond waren, war, die Russen haben sich nicht beschwert.
Ja, das hört sich profan an.
Das ist echt, wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt, sehr schlüssig.
Finde ich auch. Ich finde, das ist ein Argument aus Beton. Zunächst mal, die Russen waren nicht blöd. Die Russen hatten die technischen Möglichkeiten, selber nie dagewesene Raumflüge durchzuführen. Das heißt, sie hatten die Infrastruktur, um Satelliten zu verfolgen. Sie hatten zum Beispiel eine Flotte von speziellen Funkkommunikationsschiffen. Zum Beispiel die Kosmonaut Juri Gagarin. Ein tolles Schiff. Jedes Mal, wenn eine Apollo-Mission anstand, dampfte dieses Schiff zu den Kanarischen Inseln nach Gran Canaria. Dort gab es in seiner Zeit eine Bodenstation der NASA, die auch mit der Bahnverfolgung der Apollo-Missionen zu tun hatte. Die haben sich da niedergelassen, Anker hoch, rote Fahne hoch und dann haben sie zugehört, was da gefunkt worden ist. Die hätten das jederzeit mitbekommen, wenn da ein falscher Zaubergang gelaufen wäre.
Aber da kommen bestimmt auch die Verschwörungstheoretiker und sagen, die Russen waren ja auch nie auf dem Mond und wenn die jetzt anfangen, sich bei den Amerikanern zu beschweren, dann fliegt das ja auch auf.
Ja, gerade weil die Russen nicht auf dem Mond waren, ist das ein Argument gegen die Fälschung. Die Russen haben es nämlich auch versucht, zum Mond zu fliegen. Die haben das lange Zeit geheim gehalten, aber tatsächlich haben sie mit dem gleichen volkswirtschaftlichen und technischen Aufwand versucht, zum Mond zu kommen. Die Russen haben aber leider am falschen Ende die falsche technische Entscheidung getroffen. Die Amerikaner haben die Saturn V komplett neu entwickelt, vor allen Dingen auch mit einer Erststufe, die mit fünf sehr großen Raketen, mit fünf sehr großen Triebwerken funktioniert. Die Russen haben sich davor gescheut, diese sehr aufwändige Entwicklung des riesen Triebwerks an Angriff zu nehmen und haben versucht, eine Rakete mit einer Erststufe zu bauen, die 30 kleinere Raketen hat. Sie hatten gehofft, dass es dabei weniger Entwicklungsrisiko gäbe, aber da haben sie sich getäuscht, da gab es Probleme, von denen die vorher nichts geahnt haben, diese niemals gelöst haben, also diese Rakete ist einmal auf dem Startplatz explodiert und ansonsten viermal während des Fluges der ersten Stufe und 1971 haben die Russen dann schließlich die Entwicklung dieser Rakete aufgegeben, weil es kein Ende in Sicht gab. Aus dieser Niederlage heraus gibt es da noch mehr Motivation vor die Presse zu treten, wenn der Klassenfeind da mit einer Fälschung versucht, den Anschein einer gelungenen Mondlandung zu erwecken. Und gerade unter dem Hintergrund der technischen Niederlage hat man noch mehr Motivation, sowas da sofort an die Öffentlichkeit zu melden. Und die Russen hätten erstmal durch ihre technischen Raumfahrtmöglichkeiten, zweitens mal durch den größten Geheimdienst der Geschichte, dem KGB, die Möglichkeit gehabt, da das herauszufinden. Und ich finde es vollkommen absurd da zu behaupten, die Russen hätten irgendwie ein Interesse daran gehabt, das damit zu spielen bei so einer Geschichte. Zu der Zeit gab es einen blutigen Krieg zwischen den Supermächten, die haben sich wirklich nicht nur mit Worten, sondern auch mit Kugeln beharkt in Stellvertreterkriegen wie in Vietnam. Da haben tatsächlich auch Russen gegen Amerikaner blutig gekämpft und es kann nicht sein, dass es gleichzeitig da mit so einer Verschwörung da kooperiert wird. Das macht keinen Sinn.
Bist du eigentlich auch ein Mondlandungsopfer?
Ja, ich bin auch ein Mondlandungsopfer. Ich habe zwar keine klare Erinnerung mehr an die Apollo 11. Da war ich sechs Jahre alt. Aber die letzte Mission habe ich auf jeden Fall so im schläfrigen Zustand noch vom Fernseher schwarz-weiß mitbekommen und ich fand es hochinteressant. Die Verschwörung kann auch nur bestätigen, was der Rainer gesagt hat. Ich glaube, das schlagendste Argument neben der erdrückenden Beweislast, die es heute gibt anhand von unbemannten Sonden und Bildern, wo man Spuren und die Relikte des Mondlande-Moduls der Fähre noch sieht, und man hat es ja mittlerweile aufgenommen aus dem Mondorbit. Aber das schlagendste Argument in meiner Meinung nach ist von Gene Cernan. Er hat gesagt, warum hätten wir etwas neunmal faken sollen? Also das macht keinen Sinn.
Das stimmt, einmal hätte ja gereicht.
Eben, eben. Und vermutlich, sag ich mal...
Stanley Kubrick hat ja eigentlich auch keinen Genre zweimal gemacht. Und dann steht er ja 2001.
Und vermutlich, das müsste man jetzt Filmexperten nachrechnen lassen, aber es könnte sein, dass die gesamten Special Effects praktisch inklusive Kulisse teurer gekommen wären, wie das Original Mondlande-Programm.
Ja, ja, da gab es auch neulich einen schönen Artikel im Netz. Muss ich noch mal raussuchen, wo jemand auch sehr flüssig dargelegt hat, dass die Tricktechnik damals einfach auch gar nicht gereicht hätte. Also selbst wenn Stanley Kubrick es gewollt hätte, hätte es gar nicht hinbekommen, es wäre nicht möglich gewesen, diese Bilder in der Form zu produzieren, so Schwerkraft und so weiter. Da gab es dann diese Thesen mit, das ist ja dann irgendwie langsamer aufgenommen worden oder schneller, so und er hat dann sehr schlüssig dargelegt, dass also einfach mit der damaligen Technik das so überhaupt gar nicht möglich gewesen wird. Ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal so hin. Was mich jetzt aber noch mal interessiert ist, der Geist, weil ich bin so ein bisschen so kurz danach, also ich hätte jetzt, glaube ich, so theoretisch mit fünf Jahren oder so noch die Gelegenheit gehabt, da vielleicht so das letzte Fähnchen noch zu sehen, aber das hat dann glaube ich auch noch gedauert, bis der Fernseher irgendwie bei uns einzugiert. Von daher habe ich das so ein bisschen verpasst. Aber was habt ihr denn so in Erinnerung, wie das den Geist der Gesellschaft geändert hat, weil wir über Science Fiction reden und eben über diese finale Erlangung. Also alle wollten das immer so, Mond, Mond, Mond, Mond, dann war man dann irgendwie da. Und dann, was war dann? Also ich meine, hat sich da sofort was verändert? War auf einmal so die Gesellschaft, die Menschheit auf einmal anders drauf oder?
Ganz bestimmt, auch wenn ich jetzt so zurückblick, wenn man mal so das letzte Jahrhundert so an sich Revue passieren lässt. Da war ja eigentlich nicht viel, an das man sich gerne erinnert, aber so was da so nicht wahr ist, da gab es viele Kriege und alle möglichen Weltkatastrophen, aber das, woran man sich noch gerne dran erinnert, das ist so die Mondlandung. Da ist die Menschheit wirklich nach... Ja gut, Beatles auch. Ja, stimmt.
Und Mondlandung.
Und Mondlandung, ja. Aber das ist doch so was als Positives, in Erinnerungen bleibt, finde ich. Aber ich bin ganz sicher, dass die Mondlandung viele Menschen auch wirklich tief beeindruckt haben. Und das sieht man auch an den Verschwörungstheorien. Wenn das nicht irgendwie den Menschen nahegegangen wäre, dann würde doch kein Hahn mehr danach krähen. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass die Leute das für diskussionswürdig halten, ist auch eigentlich ein Indiz dafür, wie tief das die Leute auch berührt hat, was da passiert ist. Aber was treibt die denn?
Hast du das mal verstanden?
Bitte was?
Na was treibt die denn? Ich meine, so viel Zeit und Energie darauf zu verschwinden.
Das ist in der ersten Linie wichtig, Thor. Die Mondlandungen waren ja wie gesagt ein Ereignis, das von vielen Menschen als das herausragende Ereignis des 20. Jahrhunderts gesehen wurde und wenn jetzt da so ein klug Mensch kommt und sagt, hey, das war gefälscht, dann hat man ja damit die Chance eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen. Und das ist ja auch so, die Leute verkaufen Bücher und was weiß ich und damit kann man schon Aufmerksamkeit erlangen. Aber die Leute wollen Aufmerksamkeit und sich hervortun, indem sie da die tatsächlichen hohen Leistungen anderer Menschen da diffamieren und runterreden.
Trotzdem war dann irgendwie mit dem Mond aber auch so ein bisschen alles erreicht. Hast du den Eindruck, dass dann so der nächste Schritt war nicht mehr so offensichtlich?
Ja, das wird man sehen, da haben die Amerikaner, vor allen Dingen die Russen auch ein bisschen in der Luft gehangen. Was macht man jetzt? Jetzt fahren wir auf den Mond, damit haben wir schon den Höhepunkt vorweggenommen.
Also Raumfahrt ist doch jetzt durchgespielt.
Wir waren da. Das hängt natürlich auch wahrscheinlich mit den Budgets zusammen, die damals ja auch während der Mondlandung schon runtergesetzt wurden, nachdem das politische Ziel erreicht war, was Kennedy gesteckt hat, eben bis zum Ende des Jahrzehnts. Man hat gewonnen gegenüber den Russen und Russland hat sich dann aufs Erdorbit fokussiert mit Raumstationen, Salyut auf Forschung in der Erdumlaufbahn. Es sind ja noch drei weitere Mondlandungen geplant gewesen, eine davon auf der Rückseite und die hat man alle praktisch nicht verwirklicht. Da sind ja die Nazis dann, nicht? Ja, die nächste Verschwörungstheorie. Grundsätzlich kamen dann ja auch andere Dinge zu, nämlich ein Politikwechsel in den USA. Wie Rainer schon gesagt hat, ist gerade der Vietnamkrieg, der zunehmend Aufmerksamkeit ins Tagesgeschehen gerückt hat.
Und auch Ressourcen.
Und Ressourcen. Und natürlich hat man sicherlich ein Problem dahingehend gehabt. Das haben wir übrigens heute oftmals auch noch. Ziel erreicht, nächstes, was kommt dann? Also es hat dann die Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr so interessiert. Und das war ja auch erst politisch, bevor dann sukzessive die Wissenschaft nachrückte und die Forschung nachrückte und dann mit der letzten Apollo-Mission auch durch Harrison Schmidt, eben der erste Geologe, da auf den Mond kam. Aber der Mond rückte dann nach dem Erreichen des Ziels eben raus aus dem öffentlichen Fokus. Und ähnliche Dinge hätten wir wahrscheinlich heute auch. Wenn man jetzt heute einmal zum Mars fliegen würde, wäre das super en vogue. Und ich sag mal, nach der 4. und 5. Mission würde das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr wirklich wahrgenommen in der Öffentlichkeit. Die Gefahr besteht einfach. Und so muss man, sag mal, in der Community meines Erachtens immer für interessante Fakten und für interessante Gesprächstoffe sorgen. Nicht für Verschwörungstheorien im Übrigen.
Aber im Prinzip, das mit dem Geologen, das war ja so, bis dahin wurden ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit immer nur Piloten und sonstige Hau-Draufs da hochgeschickt, weil man sich primär erst mal so über die Belastung Gedanken gemacht hat. Aber so diese Idee, dass das Ganze wirklich so einen wissenschaftlichen Nutzen hat, die hat sich nicht jedem sofort erschlossen. Also eigentlich ist der Abschluss dieser Mondlandung insofern auch so ein Paradigmenwechsel, als das dann zunächst, ich deute das jetzt gerade mal so, dass dann sozusagen überhaupt erst die Erkenntnis sich durchgesetzt hat, dass das nicht nur cool ist, sondern vielleicht sogar auch nützlich.
Also die Hauptmotivation für die Apollo Mission war, den Russen mal zu zeigen, wo es lang geht. Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Das war die politische Triebfede, aber das hat sich dann nachher vollkommen verselbstständigt. Also Wissenschaft war immer ein wichtiger Teil, aber man hat zunächst gedacht, dass man den wissenschaftlichen Teil, also zunächst mal wollte man einfach da sein, auf dem Mond, Flagge, Boots, Flags and Footprints hieß das Motto auch ganz zu Anfang. Aber dann hat man auch festgestellt, dass man mit den Leuten, die da sind, da erstklassige Wissenschaft machen kann. Das hat auch bei den ersten Flügen gut funktioniert. Also die Astronauten, die man da ausgesucht hatte, die hat man nicht einfach so raus ausgesucht. Das war wirklich hochintelligente und fähige Ingenieure. Die haben auch erst mal Motivation und auch die Fähigkeit gehabt, Wissenschaft da auszuführen. Man hat die intensiv geschult. Die haben sehr ausführliche Ausbildung in Geologie gekriegt und die haben von Fachleuten gelernt, nach was sie da schauen müssen und wie sie die Proben nehmen müssen und was sie da machen müssen. Das ist sehr gut gelaufen, aber nachdem man dann erst die Erfahrung mit den ersten Landungen hatte und nachdem man gesehen hat, dass die technischen Anforderungen da nicht so kritisch sind, dass man sie nur von irgendwelchen ausgebildeten Kampffiloten da machen lassen kann, da hat man sich überlegt, dass es doch sinnvoll wäre, einen Vollblutgeologen da, der auch fast von der Geologie versteht, dass man dem Wissenschaftler dann das Fliegen beibringen, statt den Fliegern in die Wissenschaft beizubringen. Das hat gut funktioniert, aber ich hätte das in meinen Augen eher machen sollen.
Das heißt, ihr könnt alle fliegen?
Ja, ich bin ein Mitflieger. Ich fliege gerne bei den ESOG-Piloten mit. Theoretisch ist es auch möglich, dass ich, wenn keiner guckt, mal fliege. Aber nicht, dass ich das gelernt hätte.
Ich bin ja schon mal geflogen. Ich bin ja tatsächlich mal geschwebt. Im Rahmen von Raumzeit hat es mich ja mal in den Parabelflieger verschlagen. Das war ein echtes Privileg und wirklich merkwürdig. Dann habe ich dann auch gemerkt, wie schwierig das ist, anderen Leuten dann zu erklären, wie es war.
Ich stammel mich auf schon seit zehn Jahren bei der PR-Abteilung ein, dass ich das auch mal darf.
Nehmt euch ein Herz. Zurück zu den Mythen. Vielleicht sollten wir auch noch mal den Science-Fiction ein bisschen einbringen. Das war ja dann auch, ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wer da so zuerst kam, aber eben so mit dieser ganzen ersten Begeisterung für Raumfahrt rund um den Mond kam dann eben auch dieses Science-Fiction-Genre an und fing auch an, sehr, weiß nicht, kann man das wissenschaftlich nennen, also halt eben, naja eben die Fiction da mit reinzubringen. Was man denn nicht eigentlich mal alles so machen müsste. Man bräuchte ja auch mal so Raumstationen, das wär ja super und am besten gleich auch noch Hotels im Orbit. Wobei, da gab's irgendwie auch nur Kubrick, der das irgendwie gemacht hat. Der Rest will immer nur schnell durch die Gegend düsen.
Ja und ich mein, es gab natürlich verschiedene Trends, wenn man sich so, ich sag mal jetzt von den 50ern bis zu den 80ern oder 90ern, das betrachtet, gab es am Anfang hier, ich sag mal, Destination Moon und die Kubrick-Sachen, die waren sehr technisch und sehr vom Heldenmut geprägt und das Verschieben der Grenzen. Und danach gab es mal hier ein Flower-Power-Zeit, eher doch sozialkritische Dinge, wo die Gesellschaft in Frage gestellt wurde, dass der Mensch in Frage gestellt wird oder wurde. Und dann kam natürlich so nach und nach Stanley Kubrick mit 2001, wo das doch schon sehr real aussah, jetzt raumfahrtechnisch und sehr, wie soll ich sagen, auch ethisch weit ging. Und dann eben bis in die 70er, 80er mit Star Wars und die ganzen Star Trek-Serien. Das ist eine riesen Bandbreite und da ist, glaube ich, für jeden Geschmack was dabei. Jetzt habe ich deine Frage vergessen.
Na ja, es ist schon mal interessant, was überhaupt da alles reinprojiziert wurde. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite war es natürlich so die Begeisterung für die Technik und so ein bisschen auch so die Vorstellung, was eigentlich jetzt mal so als Nächstes sein müsste. Weil Mond war ja dann auch irgendwie durch. So, ja, hat man ja irgendwie geschafft, damit kann man jetzt nicht mehr groß Leute hinterm Ofen herholen. Nee, jetzt brauchte man halt schon überdimensionale Raumschiffe, wo man ja tausende lang irgendwie durchs All schippern kann ohne Probleme und jeden Tag neue lustige Episoden erleben kann. So Star Trek war ja da immer sehr. Und aber eben auch immer begleitet von so einem neuen pangalaktischen Gesellschaftsbild. Auf einmal gab es unzählige Völker und Rassen, die irgendwie alle irgendwie geordnet sind und sich in Allianzen ab und zu natürlich auch mal in Kriegen und so weiter finden. Aber es gab da immer so eine gute Kraft, die im Prinzip ja das dann doch irgendwie geregelt bekommt. Im Prinzip natürlich auch ein Abbild wiederum der Gesellschaft hier auf der Erde, die genau damit natürlich noch ein totales Problem hatte. Also die Amerikaner und die Russen hatten ja nun diesen Wettlauf nicht nur in der Raumfahrt, sondern einfach auch dieser Wettbewerb um das richtige Gesellschaftsbild und was denn nun so richtig ist in den ganzen Kriegen, die damit zusammenhängen. So hat sich ja die Science-Fiction quasi inspiriert von der Technik, an der Stelle genauso ja auch dem Gesellschaftsbild angenommen. Und ich finde das insofern auch sehr interessant, als ich hier zum Beispiel mit Samantha Christopheretti zusammen gesprochen hatte über die Astronautenausbildung, auch was Sigmund Jähn so hat anklingen lassen. Immer wenn die erfahrenen Astronauten auch so aus ihrer Zeit berichten, es herrscht ein unfassbarer internationaler Geist in dieser Raumfahrtszene. Also so diese, da gibt es überhaupt keine, also nicht nur keine Grenzen mehr, sondern so diese ganze Kollaboration, das ist vollkommen selbstverständlich, so selbstverständlich, dass ihr jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen wärt, wahrscheinlich darüber zu reden.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch eine Sache, die man so bei Star Trek beobachten kann. Star Trek ist ja auch so ein Kind der des ersten Raumfahrts, der ersten Raumfahrtbegeisterung. Und daher wurde ja gleich weitergedacht, welche gesellschaftlichen Bedeutungen, welche gesellschaftliche Bedeutung die Raumfahrt hat. Da wurde auch dieser, diese Multikulti-Charakter da praktisch schon angesprochen. Da wurden, in Star Trek hat es zum ersten Mal im Film einen Kuss zwischen einem weißhäutigen Mann und einer schwarzen Frau gegeben. Das war damals ein Riesenskandal, aber das war Teil des Konzeptes. Also Raumfahrt ist eine Multikulti-Angelegenheit und bringt die Menschen nach vorne. Und das wurde dann auch natürlich durch die freundschaftliche Zusammenarbeit mit manchen intergalaktischen Zivilisationen und mit dem feindlichen Gegenvertret von anderen da weiter ausgesponnen. Jedenfalls hat Star Trek da so ein positives Bild der Zukunft gezeigt, also die Menschheit kommt weiter und überwindet gesellschaftliche Probleme. Und sieht man ja auch, dass da vorne auf der Brücke, vorne links, der Chekhov gesessen hat, der damals noch zu einem bitter verfeineten Staat gehörte. Ich hatte übrigens mal die Gelegenheit mit dem Walter König von Flight Dynamics Engineer zu reden. Und er hat sich wirklich gefreut, dass ich ihm wahrheitsgemäß berichtet hatte, dass er dazu beigetragen hat mit seiner Darstellung, dass ich da auch diesen Weg eingeschlagen habe.
Kollegen sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Also er fühlt sich tatsächlich auch als Teil des Ganzen.
Find ich klasse. Und ich kann vielleicht noch ergänzen, tatsächlich so, wenn wir uns die internationale Raumstation zum Beispiel anschauen, da ist es absolut richtig, dass die gut funktionierende internationale Kooperation eigentlich völlig untergeht. Das wird gar nicht mehr wirklich wahrgenommen, ist aber de facto. Ja, eigentlich hat man sich schon dran gewöhnt. Und man wird das erst merken, wenn die ISS zu Ende geht. Und was kommt denn dann? Also das ist meine Prognose. Wenn wir merken, ups, jetzt hat sie ihre Lebenszauber erreicht und Forschungsprogramme laufen aus und jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich etwas Neues. Und da kommt aber vielleicht nicht, oder nicht eine solche Riesenstation nochmal. Dann wird man wahrscheinlich erst merken, hoppla, ja, ist doch gar nicht schlecht gewesen. Also eigentlich haben wir auf der ISS eine Multikulti-Crew, oder vielfache Multikulti-Crew, so muss man ja sagen, eine Logistikflotte international, Europa, Japan, Russland, USA, die sie versorgt, am Leben erhält, und ein tolles Forschungsprogramm, sowohl bei der NASA als auch in Russland, als auch in Europa, in Japan. Also ich denke, das ist das, was mich eigentlich begeistert, eben dass es so funktioniert, dass man es eigentlich im Prinzip als selbstverständlich wahrnimmt, oder gar nicht mehr wirklich als extra Punkt rausarbeitet. Es ist einfach da, es funktioniert. Das heißt aber nicht, dass man die Nationalität aufgibt, aber in dem Kontext läuft es super.
Du bist ja selber, vielleicht mal um etwas Aktuelles aufzugreifen, du bist ja auch selber an einer interessanten Schnittstelle dran. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, bei der ISS und der Zukunft der ATV-Technik, also ATV muss man vielleicht noch kurz sagen, das Automated Transfer-Wiegel, war hier übrigens auch schon mal ein Thema natürlich bei Raumzeit, 17. Ausgabe des Versorgungsmoduls der Europäer, was eben als erstes geschafft hat, so einen vollautomatischen Docking-Prozess zu machen, und das nicht nur irgendwie, sondern eben sehr gut. Das ist ja jetzt im Prinzip ausgewählt, als die technische Basis für die Kapsel mit dem amerikanischen Astronauten oder auch andere Astronauten künftig zur ISS fliegen sollen. Ist ja eigentlich auch ungewöhnlich, dass jetzt die Amerikaner ihrer Astronauten den europäischen Kapseln vertrauen.
Das stimmt, das ist eigentlich das erste Mal, dass uns die NASA hier auf den kritischen Pfad mitnimmt und sich abhängig macht von einem Antriebs- und Ressourcenmodul aus Europa für ihre Orionkapsel. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt durch den letzten Beschluss auf der Ministerratskonferenz erstmal ein Entwicklungsprogramm gemeinsam mit der NASA gestartet. Das ist jetzt zwar kein klassisches Entwicklungsprogramm wie ein vollwertiges ATV, aber es basiert eben da, wo es Sinn macht auf ATV-Technologie. Und wenn wir es hinbekommen, 2017 so geplant im Moment, den ersten unbemannten Flug zu machen, das wäre eine fantastische Sache. Und dann gibt es unter Umständen Optionen für weitere von diesen Service-Modulen. Und ich sage mal, ich spreche jetzt persönlich, für mich wäre das natürlich eine wunderbare Sache, wenn wir quasi, wir Europäer, bei jeder Explorationsmission, wo auch immer Orion hinfliegt, mit dem Service- und Antriebsmodul dabei sind. Da ist natürlich noch viel Arbeit zu tun. Auch die politischen Entscheidungen müssen entsprechend getroffen werden. Das ist also keine Trivialität, aber es wäre jetzt auf meine eigene Sicht eine sehr schöne Sache. Und man hätte natürlich bei der zweiten Mission eine Mitfluggelegenheit um den Mond herum, die klassische Acht, 2020, 2021. Ich persönlich, ich spreche jetzt ein bisschen vor, ich würde sehr gerne Alexander Gerst da auf einem Platz sehen, um den Mond herum. Das würde mir persönlich sehr gut gefallen.
Warum fliegt ihr um den Mond herum?
Das wird erstmal getestet um den Mond herum. Wir haben noch keine Landung da. Das kommt erst später. Die Amerikaner sind mit dem Mondlandegerät technisch noch nicht fertig. Wo sie sehr weit sind, ist die Kapsel. Wir müssen mit dem Service-Modul nachziehen. Die Flug-Einheit 1, 2017. Darüber hinaus gibt es noch keine politischen Beschlüsse. Das wäre, wenn man in die Zukunft schaut, für mich eine sehr schöne Option. Eine sehr schöne Perspektive für das Europäische Astronauten-Korps.
Eine universelle Reisenkapsel. Das war ja dann sozusagen auch schon wieder auf dem Weg des Science-Fiction, weil ich meine, wenn jetzt die Raumstation durchgespielt ist, der Level, dann schlagen wir nach im Science-Fiction-Almanach. Dann müsste ja jetzt das Hotel von Stanley Kubrick dann auch mal, das fände ich auch mal ganz gut.
Ja, da denkt man ja auch danach. Es gibt ja...
Mehr rotierende Sachen.
Diese rotierenden Raumstationen sind out mittlerweile. Da hat man festgestellt, dass es da Probleme gibt. Das ist natürlich eine schöne Sache, dass man da künstliche Gravitation erzeugt. Das macht... Das schafft viel Erleichterung. Das Problem ist, dass man sich ziemlich sicher ist, dass durch die Coriolis-Beschleunigung, die dabei auftritt, den Astronauten eigentlich fortwährend schlecht wäre. Und das will man auch nicht. Also, das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht geben. Mittlerweile ist man sich durch die Erfahrungen auf der ISS auch ziemlich sicher, dass man das nicht braucht. Also, man kann Astronauten über sehr, sehr lange Zeit in einem akzeptablen Fitnesszustand halten. Also, man kann wirklich alle Missionen, die in Frage kommen, auch die 1000-Tage-Mission zum Mars, die so...
Ja, wenn man schon im Weltall ist, dann will man auch schweben. Das kann ich mittlerweile auch ganz gut nachvollziehen. Das stimmt schon.
Also, man ist jetzt sicher, dass das heutzutage kein Thema ist.
Jetzt schneiden wir gerade einen interessanten Punkt an, weil Science-Fiction heißt ja auch immer viel, also nicht nur so, was die gesellschaftliche Vision ist oder was so die nächste große Grenze ist. Es gibt ja auch viele sehr konkrete Vorstellungen davon, was so technisch machbar sein soll. Und ich meine, so eine schlechte Idee war das ja jetzt ja eigentlich nicht mit der Rotation. Funktioniert vielleicht so ein Detail nicht, war ja schon mal ganz gut angepeilt. Gibt es denn da noch so ein paar andere Konzepte, die sich so in der Literatur oder den Fernsehen, Filmen, Welten so ausgebreitet hat, dass da so dran sehr geglaubt wurde, dass es auch genug Wissenschaftler gab, die dann jetzt auch auf dem Weg sind, das zu implementieren?
Ja, also das allerheißeste von allen ist, finde ich, der Roman The Fountains of Paradise von Stanley Kubrick, von Arthur C. Clarke natürlich. Und da in diesem Roman malt er den Space Elevator aus. Das heißt, ein technisches Gerät, das es ermöglicht, von der Erdummerfläche mit einer Fahrstuhlkapsel in die Erdumlaufbahn zu fahren. Das ist technisch machbar. Vorausgesetzt, es gibt das nötige Material dazu. Man weiß schon, welches Material das nur sein kann, nämlich Kohlenstoff-Nanoröhrchen. Das sind Kohlenstoffmoleküle, die Röhrchen formen. Wenn es gelingt, die in Produktionsreif mit einer Länge herzustellen, die im paar Dutzend Meter Bereich liegt, dann kann man damit die Aufzugsseile spinnen. Das Verhältnis aus Reißfestigkeit und Tragfähigkeit ist sensationell.
Dann spart man sich die ganzen Qualmwolken und den Lärm beim Start. Dann geht der Astronaut einfach nur noch in den Fahrstuhl und drückt auf 1.367.479 und dann geht es nach oben.
Das spart nicht nur Geld beim Start. Man kriegt auch komplett neue technische Möglichkeiten. Heutzutage real existierende Satelliten werden für den Start gebaut. Der ganze Satellit ist von der Struktur her und von den Randbedingungen her für den Start ausgelegt. Wenn man einmal im All ist, dann braucht man diese ganzen Features gar nicht mehr. Das könnte man ja verschenken. Man könnte wirklich sehr viel bessere und sehr viel preiswertere Satelliten bauen, die damit als Dutzendware ins All befördert werden können. Damit kann man ganz neue Sachen machen, von denen man heutzutage nicht träumt. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man den Space Elevator richtig baut, dann kann man damit auch die ganze Reise durch das Sonnensystem dramatisch vereinfachen, weil man gleich die Erdrotation ausnutzen kann, um die Dinger praktisch bis zum Pluto zu speisen.
Das heißt, man klettert sozusagen erstmal hoch und dann wird man automatisch die ganze Zeit beschleunigt, als würde man die ganze Zeit so eine Schleuder durch die Gegend...
So kann man sich das vorstellen.
Und dann lässt man einfach los und dann ist man schon so gut wie da. Genau, ja.
Also das ist eine tolle Sache. Das einzige Problem ist, dieses Material ist noch nicht verfügbar, außer im Labor und in nicht befriedigender Stranglänge. Aber das ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass das mal klappt. Und was mich auch wirklich beeindruckt hat, der Arthur C. Clarke hat in diesem Roman auch schon beim Namen genannt, dass das Material, das für den Weltraumaufzug geeignet ist, fantastisch geeignet ist für den perfekten Käsehobel. Weil das bei extrem dünner Ausführung eine sehr große Festigkeit hat. Und so was ist doch, da sieht man auch die wahren Visionäre.
Ja, das ist der Rücklauf der wissenschaftlichen Entwicklung in so einem täglichen Alltag. Es gibt ja so vieles, was man sich heute nicht mehr wegdenken kann. So was irgendwie auf der Raumfahrt kommt, aber dass jetzt auch noch der Käsehobel revolutioniert wird.
Soll man gar nicht glauben.
Ja, hat mich jetzt überrascht. Also ehrlich gesagt, Käse ist schon ein Problem.
Ist doch mal ein Spin-in oder ein Spin-off, je nachdem von welcher Richtung man das sieht. Ich bin bei dem Aufzug, so gern ich den hätte, ein bisschen zurückhaltender. Weil ich nicht glaube, dass man Materialien irgendwann herstellen kann, die diese Reißlängen aufweisen. Aber so eine Struktur ist natürlich auch anfällig gegen Debris und gegen was auch immer. Da ist viel zu tun, sicherlich. Auf die nächste Zukunft werden wir leider mit den Raketen klassischer Art leben müssen. Was nicht heißt, dass wir nicht daran tun sollten, technisch weiterzukommen. Für mich interessant ist eine Entwicklung in den USA von Ad Astra, die Plasmatriebwerke. Die haben also Szenarien durchgerechnet, wo sie in zwischen 50 und 80 Tagen zum Mars fliegen, mit hochem Impuls und hohem Schub. Und auch jede Art von Treibstoffen. Verbrannt wird das nicht, es wird einfach beschleunigt, elektrisch und ausgestoßen. Die sind sehr weit im Labor, brauchen natürlich elektrische Energie dafür. Das ist natürlich das zweite Problem, wenn wir jetzt mal Richtung Mars uns eine Mission denken. Also für mich jetzt, ich sag mal, so sehr ich zu Mars fliegen möchte oder das sehen möchte, aber tausend Tage oder mehr macht, macht für mich relativ wenig Sinn, weil die Leute und die Crew, die da oben ist, die haben doch erhebliche gesundheitliche Einschränkungen zu überstehen und alleine die Strahlung und das ganze Environment, auch die Psychologie, wenn man eingeschossen ist auf eine Mars-Trajektorie mit klassischem Ansatz, gibt es kein Zurück mehr. Ich muss da hin und ich kann die Mission nicht abbrechen im Prinzip. Und ich glaube, das macht es schwierig. Ich denke, wir müssen technologisch weiterkommen, um dann mit einem neuen System weiter zu kommen, weiter zu gehen. Und für mich ist also dieses Orion mit dem Service-Modul eine Art Zwischenlösung, um dann irgendwann mal vielleicht mit dem Wasimir-Antrieb, wenn er dann kommt und serienreif werden sollte, verbunden natürlich mit Reaktoren, die elektrische Energie in genügender Menge produzieren können. Ich denke, wenn man diese Kombination schafft, dann kann ich auch die Grenze der menschlichen Exploration im Sonnensystem weiter verschieben. Aber ich habe also für mich, sagen wir, der klassische Missionsansatz einer Mars-Mission, wie man ja alle 20 Jahre mal von USA vorgeschlagen hört, diese Cowboy-Mission. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da ein bisschen zurückhaltender.
Cowboy-Mission im Sinne von so als Einbahnstraße?
Apollo-like, ja. Hin und Flagge im Boden, Fußabdruck, ein paar Bröbchen eingepackt und zurück. Es ist natürlich abzuwägen, aber wenn ich zu entscheiden hätte, würde ich die Crew lieber vernünftig hinbefördern und auch wieder vernünftig zurückbringen und in kürzerer Zeit. Das macht wesentlich mehr Sinn. Wenn ich 80 Tage für eine Strecke vielleicht brauche, anstatt 300 oder 400, habe ich weniger Strahlensprävention zu treffen. Ich bin aber technologisch auch weiter. Ich denke, für mich persönlich wäre da der Weg hin, was nicht heißt, dass man die anderen Sachen nicht diskutieren kann. Mit anderen Worten, wir haben noch nicht den Impulsantrieb und den Warpantrieb, den haben wir natürlich noch nicht. Aber wir müssen halt auch an solchen Entwicklungen, das wird Jahre, Jahrzehnte gehen, bis man dort technologisch vorankommt. Aber ich denke, es ist wert, da rein zu investieren. Und die Amerikaner machen das, gerade bei den Plasma-Antrieben zum Beispiel.
Kein Warpantrieb, sagst du. Bitte? Kein Warpantrieb.
Das ist natürlich noch viel weiter in der Zukunft. Aber ich meine, jetzt geht es erst mal um die nächste Stufe.
Volker hat natürlich recht, aber unter diesem Blick muss man eine Maßexploitation sehen. Aber es zeigt doch mal, was wir für Warnduscher geworden sind. Also Captain Cook hat eine Weltumrundung gemacht. 3-4 Jahre, ist dann nach Hause gekommen, frische Unterhosen aus dem Strand geholt, Kind gezeugt und dann geht es ihm ja gleich los. Auf die nächste vierjährige Erdumrundung. Und das war viel, viel gefährlicher als eine Mars-Mission, was die damals gemacht haben. Wenn man sich so mit der Mentalität irgendwo in der Mitte treffen könnte, wäre das sicherlich nicht...
Die Frage muss sich natürlich dann jeder selber stellen. Würde ich oder würde sich jeder da reinsetzen unter dem erhöhten Risiko? Also man will ja auch die Crew gesund zurück haben, so sehe ich es zumindest. Niemand ist gegen Exploration oder einfach zu Demonstrationen. Jawohl, wir preschen voran, wir schieben die Grenze raus. Aber ich denke, für mich persönlich macht es mehr Sinn oder würde es mehr Sinn machen, wenn ich in vertretbaren Zeiträumen dahin käme, hätte ich vielleicht dann länger dort, könnte mich länger aufhalten, könnte mehr forschen, könnte vielleicht mehr Wissenschaftler mitnehmen.
Aber halt täglich duschen?
Technisch eben halt sicherer dahin kommen auch. Das ist schon ein hohes Risiko. Also ich glaube, eine Apollo-ähnliche Mars-Mission ist eine richtig große Hausnummer im Vergleich zum Mond. Und ich denke, es macht, also jetzt auch für mich als Raumfahrtingenieur gesprochen, macht es mehr Sinn, erstmal die Techniken ein Stück weiter zu treiben und eben dann den nächsten Schritt zu tun. Zum Mond sollten wir natürlich zurückgehen.
Aber was gibt es denn sonst noch, was in der Science-Fiction so an Technologien vorhergesagt wurde, was dann auch mehr oder weniger geklappt hat? Oder gibt es zumindest irgendetwas, was jetzt nicht so komplett irre erscheint, nachdem es irgendwelche Entdeckungen gegeben hat, die das vielleicht möglich machen? Also Warp-Antrieb, okay, lassen wir jetzt mal raus. Oder vielleicht doch nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Nee, Warp-Antrieb steht noch nicht so wirklich. So lange wir nirgendwo einen Plan haben, wie man unendliche Mengen von Energie erzeugen kann, umweltfreundlich und wieder generierbar. Warp-Antrieb geht, wenn Energieerzeugung keine Frage ist. Wenn man mal so ein paar Schaden sagen darf. Aber das ist noch eine Frage.
Deswegen das, was Mausen vorhört. Was in Science Fiction über die Zeit an Ideen entwickelt wurde, was im Prinzip auch tatsächlich stattgefunden hat.
Was ich richtig toll finde, ist, wie sich Leute Gedanken über das Zusammenleben von Menschen und Maschinen gemacht haben, wie auch für die Raumfahrt da relevant sind. I-Robot, Isaac Asimov, wann war das? Robert, 60er Jahre? Asimov, I-Robot, der hat sich da Gedanken...
Der Publikumsjoker ist jetzt durch.
Okay, gut, Publikumsjoker ist durch. Jedenfalls, der hat sich Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie das Zusammenleben von Menschen und Robotern geregelt werden kann und hat die Roboter-Gesetze erfunden und sich ausgemalt, wie das auch in der Raumfahrt dann zusammenspielen kann und wie das funktioniert und welche überraschenden Fehlschläge das zur Folge haben kann. Spannende Sache. Und natürlich auf 2001. Ich hab 2001 noch mal diesen Film im Kino gesehen. Ich guck den eigentlich ständig, aber 2001 auch.
Du magst den Film.
Ja, ich liebe den, heiß und indisch. Und ich finde, dass seither eigentlich kein gescheiter Science-Hitch-Film mehr gemacht worden ist.
Ja, ich bin da ganz auf deiner Seite.
Ja, aber es ist doch spannend, sich zu überlegen, wie das wohnen kann, wenn Maschinen so schlau werden wie HL9000. Also ich bin heute froh, dass mein Android-Smartphone keine Widerworte gibt, wenn ich das mal vergleiche. Andererseits sind die Fähigkeiten natürlich auch erheblich beschränkt.
Ich hab das Gefühl, wir sind da auf einem schlechten Weg mit Smartphones.
Ganz sicher, ja. Ja, aber gerade für die Raumfahrt ist das wirklich...
Widerworte sind gar nicht das Problem. Die tun so, als würden sie uns verstehen.
Aber solange man sie noch ausschalten kann, ist noch alles okay.
Ich denke, wir haben große Fortschritte in der Analytik gemacht, wenn man sich jetzt die ganzen Sonden anguckt auf dem Mars. Also praktisch die ganze chemische Analyse, die Ferndiagnostik, so nenne ich es jetzt einfach mal, das hat also gegenüber den 50ern oder 60ern erhebliche Fortschritte gemacht. Auch die Bildqualitäten natürlich, die Art und Weise, was man heute für tolle Bilder kriegen kann, in teilweise Echtzeit von Missionen, das ist schon recht beeindruckend. Und ich glaube, da sind wir nahe bei der Science-Fiction. Was man sich früher an visuellen Effekten vorgestellt hat, wird heute durch die Realität vielleicht teilweise übertroffen, von der Schönheit der Bilder. Wenn man sich hier Cassini-Holgens anguckt oder die anderen Planetmissionen, ist das doch atemberaubend, auch Hubble. Wer hätte gedacht, dass wir den Blick ins Universum so weit ausdehnen können? Für mich wäre jetzt das nächste Highlight, wenn man wirklich erdähnliche Planeten finden würde, mit Kepler zum Beispiel, mit dem NASA-Teleskop. Und hätte dann irgendwann vielleicht in der Analytik einen Beweis für Lebensspuren da draußen. Ich glaube, das könnten wir alle noch erleben. Das wäre ich, ich würde es mir wünschen. Das halte ich für hochinteressant. Für mich ist das nur eine Frage der Zeit, wenn wir diese Diagnose haben.
Wo ich ja finde, wo die Science-Fiction immer so total versagt, also sicherlich nicht alle. Und ich kenne auch nicht alles, aber gerade das, was in der Populärkultur immer so rumgeht. Also was so Transport angeht, sind die immer super. Super schnell alles irgendwie, zack, bumm, ich bin mal irgendwo am anderen Ende des Universums. Aber wenn mal sowas wie Telefonieren kommt oder so, dann wird das irgendwie schon total merkwürdig. Da ist das immer alles Klanki-Geräte. Und ja, also es ist noch nicht mal geschafft wurde, irgendwie Bildschirme, die einfach nur rechteckig sind, zu erdenken. Also dass die immer irgendwie alle so ein bisschen gebogen waren. Sodass mich dann immer schon so ein bisschen zweifeln. Was du jetzt gesagt hast mit den anderen Planeten, ich glaube, das ist natürlich auch wieder so eine neue Aussicht, dieses Leben entdecken, weil das hat, glaube ich, immer alles auch sehr getrieben. Auch in der Science-Fiction so, egal, auf welchem Steinplaneten man gerade runtergeschottert ist. Da gab es zumindest so eine durchschnittlich intelligente Zivilisation, die sich so mit üblichen Problemen rumgeschlagen hat. Also egal, wie steinwüßig das da war, Radio hatten sie auf jeden Fall. Das hat man ja selbstverständlich irgendwie angesehen. Und beim Mars war das natürlich auch ganz stark. Das war so der Angriff vom Mars. Sie wollten uns umbringen oder vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht sind sie ja noch ganz lieb, aber auf jeden Fall muss es da irgendjemand geben. Da war ja dann im Prinzip auch so die Raumfahrt sehr ernüchtert. So, ja, jetzt waren wir da und so, alles nur Stein. Ah, langweilig. Deswegen will da jetzt wahrscheinlich auch keiner mehr so richtig hin.
Ja, aber was du schon sagte, die Sache mit der Kepler-Mission der NASA, die ich richtig großartig finde, die hat ja wirklich auch die Welt sich wirklich verändert, finde ich.
Also muss man vielleicht mal erklären, das ist so das Gerät, was derzeit so am laufenden Fließband neue Planeten in anderen Sternensystemen mitnimmt.
Genau, die machen das so, indem sie einen bestimmten Punkt am Himmel anstarren, nichts anderes. Sie starren da mit einem großen Gesichtsfeld einen bestimmten Fleck am Himmel an und achten darauf, ob sich die Helligkeit der paar hunderttausend Sterne, die sich da in diesem Gesichtsfeld befinden, ob die sich ändert. Und wenn die sich ändert, dann kann das in vielen Fällen als Planet interpretiert werden, der in der Umlaufbahn um diesen Stern befindlich ist und der dann ab und zu das Licht ein bisschen abblendet. Und auf die Art und Weise hat man schon Tausende wirklich von Sternen, von Planeten gefunden. Und das ist wirklich so weit gegangen, dass man da praktisch eine andere Weltsicht mittlerweile kriegt. Früher hat man gedacht, dass Planeten absolut die Ausnahme sind. Ich glaube vor 20 Jahren oder so größtenordnungsmäßig hat man den ersten Stern mit einem Planeten überhaupt entdeckt oder den ersten Planeten eines bekannten Sterns. Und da dachte man, das sei die große Ausnahme. Mittlerweile geht man ziemlich fest davon aus, dass fast alle Sterne Planeten haben. Und das hat natürlich drastische Auswirkungen auf die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der es irgendwo Leben gibt. Und das ist schon eine revolutionäre Mission, muss man sagen.
Nur, dass es immer noch so weit weg ist alles.
Genau, ja. Es ist noch nicht in der Reichweite der Raumfahrt, so wie wir sie kennen, muss man sagen.
Es gab ja hier in der Raumzeitserie schon so wirklich einige sehr interessante Gespräche. Auch so für mich, was mir immer besonders in Erinnerung geblieben ist, ist so das Gespräch mit Stefan Scheehl hier von der RWTH, der auch diese Alpha-Magnet-Spektrometer betreut auf der ISS, was ja so ein bisschen was so der Large-Hedron-Collider auf der Erde probiert, so durch das Beschleunigen und Bummen. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was dabei rausgekommen ist, was ja auch tolle Ergebnisse geliefert hat vor kurzem mit der Entdeckung oder dem Nachweis des Higgs-Bosons, dem vermutlich Nachweis des Higgs-Bosons, das jetzt eben auf der ISS ja im Prinzip auch ähnlich geforscht wird. Da gab es ja auch gerade neue Ergebnisse. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das euch schon angeschaut habt.
Ja, ich habe das mal angeschaut. Da gibt es ein Foto übrigens in meiner Sammlung. Das ist ein sehr großer, sehr schwerer und noch teurerer Teilchendetektor, der im Weltraum ständig schaut, welche Partikel da angeflogen kommen. Man hat tatsächlich Teilchen in einer Energieverteilung beobachtet, die sich mit der Existenz von dunkler Materie so unter einen Hut bringen lassen kann, physikalisch gesehen. Das ist noch kein Beweis, dass es dunkle Materie gibt, aber das ist ein tolles Beispiel dafür, wieso die Erkenntnisbausteine langsam zusammenkommen, um tatsächlich über dunkle Materie reden zu können.
Genau, das war nämlich auch ein bisschen der Tenor des Gesprächs, was mich auch selber ein bisschen überraschert, weil er im Prinzip gleich zu Beginn anhub und meinte so, naja, seit zehn Jahren ist ja alles anders. Das hatte ich ja selber noch gar nicht so, merkt man ja nicht, wenn man morgens durch die Straßen geht, dass seit zehn Jahren alles anders ist, aber offensichtlich ist halt in der Wissenschaft diese Wahrnehmung weit verbreitet. Was ist anders? Anders ist der Blick auf das Universum, das Weltall, das, was wir bisher oder vor nicht allzu langer Zeit als alles ansahen, stellt sich raus, als ist eigentlich nur vier Prozent und der Rest ist irgendwas anderes und das wissen wir noch nicht so ganz genau. Also auf einmal tun sich wieder diese unendlichen Weiten auf, die zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt schon so ein bisschen, weiß nicht, wer geglaubt hat, ich weiß nicht, hat man das geglaubt, ich hab das zumindest geglaubt, das ist irgendwie so. Man hat jetzt so ein Erklärmodell und wir sehen das ja auch und passt schon. So und jetzt ist mal wieder so der ein oder andere Durchbruch hat stattgefunden und jetzt stellt man fest so, alles ist anders. Das Universum dehnt sich aus und es hört auch nicht auf, sich auszudehnen und wird auch immer schneller und behauptet irgendwann ist alles dunkel. Das werden wir nicht mehr so richtig miterleben, aber im Prinzip ist es ja so. Wie viel ändert sich denn jetzt so gerade so aus eurer Sicht heraus durch diese aktuelle Erkenntnislage? Sind wir jetzt sozusagen dabei, dass die Wissenschaft der Science Fiction jetzt davon galoppiert?
Manchmal hat man den Eindruck, ja. Also ich persönlich fühle mich wirklich sehr, sehr glücklich in diesen Zeiten hier zu leben, weil es noch nie so mit der Wissenschaft und der Astronomie gerade auch vorangegangen ist. Also vor, sagen wir mal, 20 Jahren war Kosmonologie noch irgendwie was für sogenannte Fuzzy-Brain-Pencil-Pushers. Das war eine Wissenschaft, die auf dem Papier stattfand. Wir haben ein paar Differentialgleichungen gelöst und das war's dann. Und dann sind sie damit auf irgendwelche Tagungen herumgezogen und alle haben gesagt, ja, ja, okay, erzählt ihr mal mit euren Gleichungen. Und plötzlich ist Kosmonologie eine Sache, die man am Himmel beobachten kann. Jetzt ist Plank dran. Genau, Plank ist eine Mission der ESA, die jetzt eigentlich gerade am Auslaufen begriffen ist. Plank ist eine Mission, die den Himmel so im Ganzen kartiert hat. Dazu braucht man einen Satelliten, der extrem kalt ist. Was man beobachten möchte, ist die sogenannte kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung. Genau, das ist das Ergebnis von Plank, die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung. Man weiß...
Das hat man doch schon 1970 auf dem Fernseher, wenn man ein Programm mitgebracht hat.
Du machst jetzt keinen Scherz. Das war jetzt nicht so gemeint, aber tatsächlich ist es so. Die jüngeren erinnern sich noch, früher gab es ja mal Sendeschluss. Einige erinnern sich noch. Bei Podcasts gibt es das auch. Früher gab es noch was, was man erleben konnte, kurz nach Mitternacht, dann war eigentlich einfach das Ende des Programms erreicht und plötzlich erschien da so ein graues Flimmern auf dem Bildschirm. Und ein winzig kleiner Teil dieses Signals, das dieses Rauschen erzeugt hat, das da sichtbar auf dem Bildschirm war, ist die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung. Die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung ist eine tolle Sache. Man hat ein Bild des Universums, das Standardmodell, das besagt, dass das Universum aus einem Urknall entstanden ist. Das ist eine Sache, die man sich nicht vorstellen kann. Unser Gehirn sagt uns, es gibt drei Dimensionen, vorne, hinten, rechts, links, oben, unten. Das Ganze ist auf irgendeine Art und Weise, die wir nicht wirklich begreifen, von der Zeit durchdrohen. Das ist ein Weltbild, das in der afrikanischen Savanne entstanden ist, durch die Evolution. Wir mussten damals zusehen, dass wir vor den Löwen wegrennen können, um zu überleben. So ist dieses Bild der Welt entstanden. Aber das Bild entspricht nicht der Realität. Wir mussten jetzt mal alle die Augen machen, uns vorzustellen, es gäbe keinen Raum und keine Zeit. Das können wir nicht. Trotzdem gab es diesen Punkt, den wir Urknall nennen, in dem ist das entstanden, was wir als Universum bezeichnen. Die ersten 380.000 Jahre war dieses Universum sehr heiß. Es hat mit ein paar Millionen Grad angefangen, ist dann abgekühlt und irgendwie 380.000 Jahre nach dem Urknall. Hat das Universum die magische Temperatur von 2.800 Grad Kelvin erreicht. Diese Temperatur war eine magische, denn bei dieser Temperatur vereinigen sich die Bestandteile des Plasmas, also die Protonen, Neutronen und Elektronen, die darum geflitzt sind, zu Atomen. Das hat zur Folge, dass das Universum von jetzt auf gleich durchsichtig geworden ist. Vorher war es eine rotglühende Pumpe, in der man die Hand vor Augen nicht sehen konnte. Plötzlich ist es durchsichtig geworden. Weil das Universum sich ausdehnt, rückt dieser Moment des Umflages praktisch in weite Ferne. Jede Sekunde ist dieser Moment weiter entfernt, auch räumlich von uns. Aber in dieser Wand, die sich da bildet, durch dieses Umschlagen, hat man praktisch ein Baby-Foto des Universums. Dieses Baby-Foto des Universums wollte man mit Plank aufnehmen. Das ist wirklich toll gelungen. Dieses Bild, das man da sieht, entspricht der Strahlung eines Körpers, der eine Temperatur von drei Grad Kelvin hat. Um das zu beobachten, braucht man einen Satelliten, der wirklich ein technisches Wunderwerk ist. Jetzt hätte ich gerne mal ein Foto von Plank, wenn das geht. Jedenfalls...
Ist ja ein Foto von Plank.
Ja, ich meine den Satelliten. Jedenfalls muss man sich vorstellen, da ist er. Man sieht hier, der hat eine Seite, die der Sonne und der Erde gleichzeitig zugewandt ist. Der ist im sogenannten Lagrange Punkt 2 untergebracht. Das ist ein Punkt auf der idealen Verbindungslinie zwischen Erde und Sonne, aber außerhalb der Distanz Erde-Sonne so 1,5 Millionen Kilometer nach außen. Und auf diesem Punkt umkreist er in einem Jahr mit der Erde die Sonne und hat da einen perfekten Aussichtspunkt, um das Universum komplett zu kartieren. Die Unterseite hier ist immer der Sonne zugewandt und hat so typischerweise eine Temperatur von 120 Grad Celsius oder 110, sowas in der Größenordnung. Um die Messungen durchzuführen, braucht man im Moment eine Temperatur von 0,1 Grad Kelvin, also 0,1 Grad über dem absoluten Nullpunkt. Und das hinzukriegen ist fast unglaublich. Jedenfalls die Leute, die die Sonne gebaut haben, haben das geschafft und er hat hervorragend funktioniert und konnte deswegen diese extrem schwache Hintergrundstrahlung perfekt kartieren. Also die meiste Information, die überhaupt drinsteckt, ist jetzt in den Händen der ESA. Und das ist eine tolle wissenschaftliche Leistung. Jedenfalls haben diese Beobachtungen, die erst vor 14 Tagen in einer Pressekonferenz bekanntgegeben wurden, zunächst mal das Bild des Universums, wie wir es bisher hatten, bestätigt. Also kein Mensch kann mehr erzählen, dass es den Urknall nicht gegeben hätte. Und auch die Bestandteile des Universums stellen sich immer deutlicher heraus. Also man weiß, dass das, was wir so als unsere Welt bezeichnen, inklusive das beobachtbare Universum, Sterne, Planeten, Galaxien, dass das nur 4,9 Prozent des Gesamtuniversums ausmacht. Harald Lesch hat mal gesagt, wir sind sozusagen die FDP des Universums.
Also ich würde mir solche Sachen nie zu eigen machen.
Aber ich wollte das immer festhalten.
Die Science-Fiction kommt hier aber gerade noch so mit. Also bei Douglas Adams gibt es ja diese Theorie, dass es etwas, was grüner Akelanfall heißt, das das Universum einfach nur ausgenießt hat. Das würde ja schon zum Urknall gewisser Hinsicht auch passen. Und auch so zu diesem Bild.
Ja, aber das ist ja eine Sache. Aber der Rest der Sache ist, dass der Rest des Universums uns vollkommen unbekannt ist. Und man ist sich sehr sicher, dass ein Viertel des Restes, nein, ein Viertel des Gesamtuniversums aus einer Sache besteht, die wir dunkle Materien nennen. Also da sind die schwarzen Löcher noch nicht dazu gezählt. Die gehören zur konventionellen Materie. Also das ist was, von dem wir eigentlich keine Ahnung haben. Aber die Wissenschaft kommt dem immer näher. Man versucht die Sache von zwei Seiten her anzugehen. Einmal in den führenden Teilchenbeschleuniger im LHC. Die möchten sich schwarze Materie, dunkle Materie selber machen. In dem großen Teilchenbeschleuniger. Und die sind da auf einem guten Weg. Aber man möchte es auch im All selber beobachten. Dazu geht dieser Partikeldetektor AMS, von dem wir eben schon gesprochen haben. Und ich bin sicher, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren wirklich sagen können, dass wir wissen, dass man das auch im Labor praktisch vor sich liegen hat. Und das ist schon ein wichtiger Bestandteil der Forschung. Wenn man gerade mal 5% des Universums sehen kann, dann ist das ein bisschen frustrierend, wenn man wissen möchte, wie das Universum tickt. Aber das wird sich vielleicht ändern.
Wie kommt denn jetzt die Science-Fiction hinterher? Gibt es da überhaupt noch gute Ideen?
Ich denke, ja, das hängt natürlich von der Fantasie ab. Ja, es ist hin und wieder schwierig, aber manchmal auch sehr einfach. Und gerade dunkle Energie, dunkle Materie, all das, was uns unbekannt ist sozusagen, wo wir keine Erklärung für haben, das ist ja sehr oft Raum für Science-Fiction oder eben für die Fiktion, wo eine Erklärung gesucht wird. Und eines ist aber sicher, um vielleicht nochmal hier drauf abzuziehen, ich meine an dem Tag, an dem wir dunkle Energie und dunkle Materie erklären können, haben wir bei jeder Abteilung 10 neue Fragen oder mehr, die wir wieder klären müssen. Also das wird nicht aufhören. Und das macht es natürlich auch spannend. Also mit jedem Stück, was man ergründet, was man exploriert, was man analysiert, erklären kann, kommen neue Felder hinzu, die sich vor uns auftun. Neue, unbekannte Fragen und unbekannte Phänomene. Und das macht es natürlich spannend, aber klar. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Bereich, wo sich die Fiktion prima austoben kann, ganz klar.
Könnte ich vielleicht nochmal dieses bunte Bild des kosmischen Hintergrundes haben? Das ist jetzt kein Publikums-Jokers-Technologie. Das gilt noch. Denn da gibt es auch eine schöne Schnittstelle von Wissenschaft und Science Fiction. Man sieht da schon mit bloßem Auge, wenn man da hinguckt, dass das nicht gleichmäßig ist. Man hat eigentlich erwartet, dass dieses Gegrisle deutlich gleichmäßiger ist. Man sieht, dass da gerade rechts von der Mitte ein großer blauer Fleck ist und links weiter rechts noch ist ein großer roter Fleck. Das kommt total verblüffend. Also die Leute haben da nicht mit gerechnet.
Wieso ist denn das überhaupt so ein Ellipsoid und keine Kugel?
Das ist eine Darstellung des ganzen Himmels. Man musste irgendwie einen Weg finden, den ganzen Himmel in einem Foto darzustellen. Deswegen hat man das so verzerrt. Das kennt man auch aus dem Dirkeatlas, wenn man die ganze Welt, die ganze Kugel so abbilden möchte. Also erst nun in einer Art und Weise den Himmel darzustellen. Jedenfalls diese großstrukturige Inhomogenität, die hat viele Leute verblüfft und haben dann sofort Leute aufgezeigt und gesagt, dafür gibt es eine Erklärung, da ist ein Parallel-Universum in unseres Reingedängel. Ja, da lacht man jetzt, aber von den anderen Erklärungen dafür, die da noch zur Diskussion stehen, ist das eigentlich die plausibelste. Man hat das wirklich gemerkt, die Leute hatten da echt Tämung, das in der Pressekonferenz zu erzählen, weil es dafür keinerlei schicke Erklärung gibt und da kann man auch schon weiter forschen. Das Naheliegendste ist, dass es da irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten bei der Datenprozessierung gab. Das kann man nicht ausschließen, aber ich bin sicher, dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sehr sorgfältig gemacht haben. Aber man weiß es nicht.
Da steckt ein Universum in unserem Universum drin?
Ja, kann gut sein. Man kann diese Möglichkeit nicht von der Hand weisen. Das ist doch schon verdammt nah an der Science Fiction. Wenn man da beobachtungsmäßige Nachweise oder Hinweise auf ein Paralleluniversum findet, in dem ganz was anderes tickt als hier, dann ist das auch eine tolle Sache.
Ich meine, das klingt jetzt so lustig, aber es steckt eine Menge drin in diesem Bild. Auf jeden Fall. Das ist jetzt schon eine signifikante Erkenntnis, die man jetzt hier gewinnen kann.
Das nächste Mal, was man daran ablesen kann, ist, das Universum ist flach. Was heißt das? Flach? Ja, genau. Man erinnert sich, früher hat der Lehrer die Kreide genommen, ist an die Tafel geschritten und hat Dreiecke gemalt und hat dargelegt, dass jedes Dreieck 180 Grad Winkelsumme hat. Das nennt man euklidische Geometrie. Und jeder Raum, in dem sowas gilt, wenn Dreiecke 180 Grad haben, ist ein euklidischer Raum, der ist flach, wie die Tafel, auf der der Lehrer das Dreieck gemalt hat. Vorplank hat man gedacht, das Universum sei irgendwie gewölbt. Das hängt davon ab, wie groß der Masseinhalt im Vergleich zur kritischen Masse ist. Das muss ich auch wieder erklären. Man weiß, es gibt ein Universum, darin gibt es Masse und Energie. Je mehr Masse und Energie da drin steckt, das ist in dem Zusammenhang das Gleiche, desto krummer wäre das Universum. Das heißt, was das konkret bedeutet, man könnte zum Beispiel drei Beobachter auf drei verschiedene Sterne stellen, und die würden jeweils den Winkel zu den anderen beiden messen. In einem flachen Universum ist die Winkel und Summe dieser Messung, auch wenn man sie nicht kommunizieren kann, 180 Grad. In einem nicht flachen Universum steht irgendwie anders, sind wir größer oder kleiner.
Das kann man jetzt hier rauslesen?
Das kann man hier rauslesen. Und zwar macht man das folgendermaßen, man weiß, wie diese größten Knubbel da entstanden sind, die man da sehen kann. Also die, die gerade noch so blaue und orange Knubbels machen. Man weiß, wie die entstehen, die sind durch akustische Schwingungen in diesem Ur, in diesem Uruniversum entstanden. Man weiß, wie groß diese Dinger in Metern sind sozusagen. Und wenn man die Winkelgröße kennt, kann man genau sagen, das Universum ist flach oder nicht. Und das Ergebnis ist, das Universum ist flach und das haut die Wissenschaftler aus den Socken. Denn, das muss ich auch erklären, denn das ist eine magische Zahl. Das ist genau der Masse-Energie-Inhalt, der nötig ist, um diese Flachheit zu erzeugen. Das Universum könnte sonst wie sein. Es könnte mehr oder weniger Materie haben. Aber Wissenschaftler glauben ungern an Zufälle. Und dass es ein Zufall ist, dass das Universum flach ist im Rahmen der beachtlichen Messgenauigkeit von 0,1 Prozent, das ist eine Sache, die die Wissenschaftler vielleicht schlafen lässt. Warum gibt es so einen Zufall? Ist das ein Zufall? Das möchte man gerne wissen, aber man weiß es nicht.
Und das heißt, jetzt ist wieder alles anders?
Ja, man hat das vorher schon geahnt. Es hat wissenschaftliche Satelliten gegeben, die das auch schon mal vorher gemessen haben, mit deutlich geringer Genauigkeit und sehr viel geringer Auflösung. Die hatten das auch schon angedeutet, aber mit Fehlerbalken, die keinen Spaß gemacht haben. Was ist mit Planck jetzt anders geworden? Jetzt weiß man es wirklich sicher. Und das ist schon beachtlich. Und eine andere Sache ist, die Tatsache, dass man überhaupt Struktur da drin sieht, ist ein Beweis dafür, dass es diese dunkle Materie gibt. Denn ich habe gesagt, in der Sekunde, bevor das Universum durchsichtig wurde, war es von Strahlung beherrscht praktisch. Und Materie, die so mit Strahlung interagiert, sowie die Materie, aus der wir bestehen, die hätte da nicht klunken können, weil sie von der Strahlung immer auseinander und verteilt auseinander geblasen worden wäre und keine Strukturen gebildet hätte. Die Tatsache, dass da aber deutlich sieht, was Strukturen sind, beweist, dass da was drin gewesen sein muss in diesem Universum, dass das mit der Strahlung nichts zu tun hatte, dass mit Strahlung nicht interagiert hat, voila, dunkle Materie, da sieht man sie praktisch vor sich.
Ja, jetzt wird das langsam plastisch. Wie groß war denn das Universum, als es 380.000 Jahre alt war? Ist das irgendwie, ist das du noch vorstellen?
Na es war auch schon unendlich, es ist schon unendlich zur Welt. Ja, das ist schwierig. Es war immer schon unendlich, aber in einer anderen Art und Weise. Ja, das sagt man so, aber es ist irgendwie ein irreleitendes Bild. Also wenn man sagt Urknall, dann stellt man sich so eine Explosion vor, die sich in den Raum ausbreitet. Sowas hat es in der Form nicht gegeben. Der Raum ist entstanden, deswegen gab es keine Explosion, die sich irgendwohin ausgebreitet hat. Ein gutes Bild dafür ist ein Fußball. Fußball ist ja klasse, die Oberfläche eines Fußballs oder einer Kugel ist begrenzt. Die kann man messen, die kann man ausrechnen. Aber wenn man auf einem Fußball als Ameise langläuft, stößt man nirgendwo an eine Grenze. Und genauso in dem Sinne unbegrenzt war das Universum immer schon. Von daher konnte man auch keinen Zollstock anlegen.
Verstehe, aber das ist nicht so einfach.
Man kann sich das nicht vorstellen, aber man soll sich nicht schenieren, ich weiß ja trotzdem, in den Kosmologen zu glauben.
Aber da kommen wir jetzt langsam zum Abschluss zu so einem Kernproblem, nämlich der Vermittelbarkeit von Raumfahrt und vor allem auch der Wissenschaft, die da mit dran hängen. Wir hatten diese großen Etappen und vielleicht auch noch die großen Ziele, die jetzt so noch vor einem liegen, weil das hat man ja schon im Fernsehen gesehen, da muss man das dann auch nochmal haben. Die die Leute halt teilweise fesseln, begeistern, aber vieles von dem, was in der komplexen Mathematik und Physik und den ganzen Erkenntnissen, die gerade die Grundlagenforschung so vor sich bringt, ist für viele dann auch eben gar nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres nachvollziehbar. Wie kann man denn diese Brücke widerschlagen? Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht gibt es ja auch eine, sozusagen fast schon eine Verpflichtung, das eben auch an die Leute wieder heranzutragen, weil es uns einfach zu weit weg ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Das machen wir ja gerade.
Ja, ja, wir sind ja ein bisschen dabei.
Ich denke, wer jetzt nicht mit Plank oder mit dem Produkt hier so zu Hause ist, klar, ist das wahrscheinlich der Öffentlichkeit, der Mann, der Frau, dem Kind auf der Straße, ist ein Problem, das zu vermitteln. Die Kunst besteht natürlich darin und das hat Rainer eigentlich, finde ich, exzellent gemacht, zumindest für mich, das runterzubrechen in einfache Worte. Ich bin jetzt hier auch kein Fachmann. Ich finde, dass das andere Bild eigentlich plastischer und ansprechender ist, nämlich die Strings, die Materie-Verteilung, was wir vorher gesehen haben. Aber in der Tat, das ist mit unserer Aufgabe, auch die Aufgabe der Agenturen, der Pressestellen und auch natürlich der Wissenschaftler, zu gucken, wie kriege ich die Botschaften, die ich jetzt hochwissenschaftlich nachweise oder erforsche, runter auf Botschaften für die Allgemeinheit. Und interessant, also gelingt es, eine Geschichte dahinter zu erzählen, gelingt es, die Leute und vor allen Dingen auch die jungen Leute zu packen, zu begeistern, für die Naturwissenschaft, für die Technik zu faszinieren. Das ist ein wesentlicher Punkt in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, sowohl sicherlich bei der ESA als auch beim DLR und anderen Agenturen. Und das ist nicht einfach. Man muss wirklich gucken, sich an die Brille von der anderen Seite aufsetzen und gucken, wie übersetze ich das verständlich, interessant, plastisch, fesselnd, das sind die Sachen. Das hat sehr viel eigentlich auch mit Bücherschreiben oder mit Geschichten erzählen zu tun. Und da ist der Link eigentlich auch ein bisschen zu Science Fiction, also jedenfalls für mich wo wir einfach eine Brücke bauen, Fakt und Fiktion und das muss verbunden werden. Hat auch mit Träumen zu tun. Wo sind unsere Träume? Haben wir sie verloren oder finden wir sie wieder? Oder ist die Realität anders, wie wir es erträumt haben ursprünglich? Das sind alles Dinge, die zusammengeführt werden müssen. Auch in der täglichen Arbeit, um Wissenschaft nach außen zu transportieren.
Wenn man wirklich interessiert ist, dann ist das natürlich alles irgendwie Atemraum. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht diese fortgesetzte Unsicherheit. Ja, also ein Universum haben wir auf jeden Fall schon mal. Vielleicht steckt da noch ein anderes mit drin. Weiß ja gar nicht, wie viele Zwiebelschalen es noch gibt. Und übrigens, man sieht sowieso nur 4% oder 4,9% von dem, was irgendwie da ist. Der Rest ist irgendwie unklar. Das ist natürlich jetzt so für so eine Menschheit, die sich über Jahrtausende mit Göttern und anderen Geschichten warmgehalten hat, teilweise sehr schwierig zu vermitteln, dass sozusagen diese Geborgenheit von einfachen Geschichten ersetzt wird durch so komplexe, unklare Aussagen.
Also mit anderen Worten, das Universum scheitert unter 5% höher oder wie?
Vielleicht muss man sozusagen auch diese Geschichte des Selbstverständnisses irgendwie auch nochmal neu erzählen. Es gibt ja dieses schöne Gleichnis von Carl Sagan, der so von dem Pale Blue Dot, dem kleinen, blassen, blauen Punkt im Nichts spricht. Und es ist auch so, wenn man sich so in Raumfahrt und Astronomie reinfallen lässt, so diese Dimension von allem und diese Kleinheit und Einzigartigkeit so des Lebens auf der Erde irgendwie auch erschreckend. Ich finde es in gewisser Hinsicht sehr positiv, weil es einem das auch sehr viel mehr schätzen lässt. Das ist ja auch das, was von Astronauten immer wieder kommt, wenn sie von ihren Missionen zurückkommen. Der Blick von oben ändert alles. Aber die Geschichte sehe ich selten erzählt. Es war viel Eroberung und viel Aufbruch und wir müssen das da mal ordnen.
Das stimmt. Ich meine, letzten Endes sind wir wahrscheinlich, also um das philosophisch vielleicht ein bisschen zu betrachten, auf der Suche nach uns selbst. Das sind ja auch Eindrücke, die Apollo-Astronauten wiedergegeben haben. Ich erinnere mich an Ellen Bienen, den wir 2010 im Gasometer in Oberhausen getroffen haben. Und der erzählt hatte zweieinhalb Stunden. Und man, der sei zurückgekommen vom Mond. Und seither beschwere er sich nicht mehr über das Wetter. Er sei froh, dass wir überhaupt eins haben. Und die ganzen kleinen Probleme, die wir hier haben, also das globale Bewusstsein hat sich, das Erfassen der Fragilität des Planeten und ich glaube, hat eine gesunde Demut gebracht. Und viele Dinge, die wir täglich durchleben, sage ich mal, geht jedem von uns so, sind einfach Nichtigkeiten. Wenn man dann so zurückkommt, glaube ich, wie jetzt ein Apollo-Astronaut oder auch nur jemand, der vielleicht auf der ISS war, der wird das anders gewichten, glaube ich. Also insofern wäre es vielleicht gar nicht mal schlecht, wenn man die Politiker dieser Welt mal eine Etage höher schickt und mal runter gucken lässt und dann vielleicht auch mal oben lässt für eine Woche und dann zurücklängt und sagt, ob sich damit vielleicht nicht ein paar Dinge relativieren und ob man da nicht mal wieder vielleicht das Uhrwerk normal zum Ticken bringt, sage ich mal, hier und da. Das war jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt, aber ich denke...
Ach, das kann ich mir schon ganz gut vorstellen mit den Politikern.
Das finde ich auch. Ich glaube, dass man vieles relativieren kann oder vieles relativiert kriegt, wenn man so eine Erfahrung gemacht hat, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Und dann denke ich mal, ja klar, das ist in jedem Zeitabschnitt sicherlich, in der menschlichen Evolution oder Historie sind neue Entdeckungen gemacht worden. Jede Zeitabschnitt hat ihre Entdeckungen und ihre Weltbilder gehabt und das wird sicherlich weitergehen. Also um anzuknüpfen an euren Dialog gerade, für mich hat sich jetzt in den zehn Jahren gefühlt natürlich nichts verändert. Ja doch, die Urknalltheoriesen, also die Expansion des Universums ist ein bisschen anders geworden, aber jetzt für mich hat sich das Leben dadurch nicht verändert. Für die Wissenschaft, die genau diese Fragen beleuchtet und untersucht, für die sehr wohl. Für die hat sich das Weltbild wahrscheinlich ziemlich stark geneigt, ja und vielleicht überraschenderweise, aber ich denke mal, das ist vielleicht auch nicht der Punkt, aber vielleicht die Geschichten dahinter, das transparent rüber zu bringen, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, gibt es Stoff und wie gesagt, es muss interessant erzählt werden und so kann man das dann auch an die an die Menschen ranbringen, die nicht tagtäglich damit umgehen, wie wir zum Beispiel.
Dem kannst du dich wahrscheinlich anschließen Rainer.
Ja, ich finde, also wir beide gehören ja zu den Leuten, die Geld damit verdienen, haufenweise Steuergelder auszugeben und ich finde das wirklich wichtig, dass so Leute wie wir dann auch darüber erzählen, was wir machen und das irgendwie auch so erzählen, dass die Leute da irgendwie was davon haben und wissen, was wir da machen, warum wir das machen.
Ich habe den Eindruck gehabt, das habt ihr jetzt auch ganz gut gemacht. Vielen Dank Rainer und Volker für das Gespräch einer ungewöhnlichen Ausgabe hier bei Raumzeit, aber mit viel ungewöhnlichen hat man es hier ja sowieso zu tun. Deswegen fand ich das super und vielen Dank hier auch an das tolle in der dunklen Materie Publikum. Und ich mache die Sendung jetzt erst mal formal zu Ende, aber wir können hier gleich auch noch ins Gespräch kommen. Das wollen wir auch noch, aber bis dahin erst mal tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.